हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है तो प्लीज एक बार चैट में बता
दीजिए।
वाइल डेविल वेरी गुड इवनिंग।
क्या मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? तो प्लीज
चैट में बता दीजिए। और तब तक के लिए दो
मिनट का वेट करते हैं। बाकी स्टूडेंट्स को
आने देते हैं। उनको ज्वाइन होने देते हैं।
ओके थैंक यू वाई डेविल
व्हाई डेविल यू आर कमिंग ऑन फर्स्ट टाइम
ऑन माय क्लास
यू आर कमिंग फर्स्ट टाइम
ओके
इससे पहले कोई क्लास ली आपने?
तो नोबडी इस कमिंग ऑन द क्लास टुडे
चलिए फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट ही करते हैं।
ओके जगत गुरु जी कैसे हो आप लोग? सब लोग
कैसे हो?
चलिए फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके टुडे वी आर बिगिंग अ न्यू एंड वेरी
एक्साइटिंग चैप्टर दैट इज प्रिपेयरिंग फॉर
एन अटैक। तो आज हम एक और नया एकिस्टिंग
चैप्टर जो हमारा चल रहा था जो हमारा सेशन
चल रहा है उसमें एक और छोटा सा सब सेक्शन
है और एक और मोर इंटरेस्टिंग जो चैप्टर्स
है या हम बोल सकते हैं जो मोर मोर
इंटरेस्टिंग सेक्शन है उसको स्टार्ट करने
जा रहे हैं दैट इज कॉल्ड प्रिपेयरिंग
फॉरेन अटैक मतलब अटैक के लिए हम कैसे
तैयार प्रिपेरेशन करनी है अगर आपको कोई भी
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक परफॉर्म करना है और
आपको इंडस्ट्री के लिए परफॉर्म करना है
अगर आपको इंडस्ट्री आपसे
ड्यूरिंग पेन टेस्टिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक परफॉर्म करवाना चाहती है तो उसके लिए
आपको हाउ टू प्रिपेयर फॉरेन अटैक मतलब
क्या-क्या चीजें आपको स्टार्टिंग में
क्योंकि अटैक ऐसे नहीं कि आप ब्लाइंडली उस
क्लास को क्या करोगे कि
आप उसको डायरेक्टली क्या करने वाले हो कि
उस क्लास में सॉरी आप उसको डायरेक्टली
अटैक करने लग जाओगे। ऐसा नहीं होता
क्योंकि जब भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक
परफॉर्म करना है या कोई भी पेन टेस्टिंग
अटैक परफॉर्म करना है तो किन-किन चीजों का
ध्यान दिया जाता है और कैसे-कैसे उस अटैक
के लिए प्रिपरेशन करना है। क्योंकि यहां
पर जो चीजें हम बात करने वाले हैं नॉट
ओनली फॉर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। ये जो आज का
जो सेशन है बेसिकली ये तो बहाना हो गया कि
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक में ये चैप्टर हम
पढ़ रहे हैं। बट जितनी भी पेन टेस्टिंग
आपको परफॉर्म करनी है रियल लाइफ में रियल
वर्ल्ड में जो भी पेन टेस्टिंग आप परफॉर्म
करोगे कोई भी अटैक परफॉर्म करे चाहे वो
इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग हो एक्सटर्नल पेन
टेस्टिंग हो कोई भी पेन टेस्टिंग आप करते
हो
तो उस टाइम पर आपको क्या करना पड़ता है कि
जो आज और कल के सेशन में हम चीजें डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं ना वो सारी चीजें क्या होती
हैं आपकी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस होती है आपके लिए एप्लीकेबल
होती हैं। ठीक है? ठीक है? वो चीजें आपको
हमेशा ध्यान में रखना ही रखना है। ये आपको
एज ए चेक ऑफ लिस्ट या एज ए हम बात करें कि
इट इज वेरीेंट स्किल। क्योंकि पेन
टेस्टिंग तो आप करते रहोगे। आपके पास बहुत
सारी नॉलेज होगी। लेकिन जो चीजें एथिकली
और लीगली चीजें होती हैं जो चीजें आपको
ध्यान में रखनी है क्योंकि पेन टेस्टिंग
से पहले बहुत बड़ी चीजें बहुत सारी चीजें
होती हैं जो आपको ध्यान में रखती रखनी
होती है जो आज की क्लास में स्पेशली मोस्ट
कॉमन क्लास है कोई भी पेन टेस्टिंग
स्टार्ट करने से पहले और कल की जो क्लास
होगी वो स्पेसिफिकली आप समझ सकते हो या कल
की भी क्लास बेसिकली सेम ही है क्योंकि
टॉपिक थोड़ा सा डिवाइडेड है टॉपिक थोड़ा
सा बड़ा है क्योंकि बहुत सारी जनरल
डिस्कशंस है जो एज ए पेंटेस्टस एज
सिक्योरिटी टेस्टर्स आपको पता होना चाहिए।
एंड जो हर एक पेन टेस्टिंग क्लासेस में या
कोई भी ट्रेनिंग है वहां पर डिस्कशन मैं
मानता हूं कि होता ही होगा क्योंकि मैंने
अटेंड किया तो वहां पर डिस्कशन होता था तो
मे बी आप कहीं पर अगर पेड ट्रेनिंग लेते
भी हो तो वहां पर वो डिस्कशन होता ही
होगा। अगर नहीं होता तो डोंट वरी आज हम
उसके बारे में डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। तो
चलिए फिर हम स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो मैं
अपनी क्लास शुरू करने से पहले अपना मैं
क्या करने वाला हूं? मैं आपके सामने एक
बहुत ही फेमस
कोट सुनाना चाहता हूं। बहुत ही फेमस
डायलॉग है किनका? मार्क ट्वेन का। ठीक है?
जो 18 67 में उन्होंने अपने न्यूज़पेपर के
आर्टिकल में लिखा था। द मोस्ट मैं एक काम
कर लेता हूं। इट
नाउ द मोस्ट आउटियस लाइ दैट कैन बी
इन्वेंटेड
विल फाइंड बिलीवर्स इफ ए मैन ओनली टेल्स
देम विद ऑल हिज माइंड। इसका मतलब समझ रहे
होंगे। अगर आपको इसका मतलब समझ में नहीं आ
रहा इसका मतलब है कि इफ यू टेल इवन द
बिगेस्ट लाइफ विद कंप्लीट कॉन्फिडेंस एंड
फुल स्ट्रेंथ पीपल विल बिलीव इट। मतलब अगर
आप पूरे कॉन्फिडेंस और पूरे ताकत के साथ
कोई सबसे बड़ा झूठ भी बोलोगे ना लोग उस पर
भी यकीन कर लेंगे। ठीक है? अगर आप कोई ऐसा
झूठ बोलते हो और उसको पूरे कॉन्फिडेंस और
पूरी ताकत के साथ या पूरी शिद्दत के साथ
उसको आप बोलते हो तो लोग उस पर भी विश्वास
कर लेंगे। और दैट इज द फाउंडेशन ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग एंड इज एग्जैक्टली इज
कॉन्फिडेंस। मतलब यह क्या चीज है?
कॉन्फिडेंस है। जिस चीज की हम बात कर रहे
हैं पूरी शिद्दत या कॉन्फिडेंस या हम बात
कर रहे हैं कि उस झूठ की जो हम पूरी ताकत
के साथ बोले तो लोग विश्वास कर लेंगे तो
वो क्या है आपका कॉन्फिडेंस है। और सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग पूरी तरीके से किसके ऊपर
बेस्ड है? आपके कॉन्फिडेंस के ऊपर। अगर
आपका कॉन्फिडेंस स्ट्रांग है। आपके पास
क्वालिटी है। अह किसी के खुद आपके अंदर
बहुत सारा कॉन्फिडेंस और किसी को आप
मैनपुलेट कर सकते हो। क्योंकि इट इज़ आल्सो
क्वालिटी। ऐसा नहीं कि आप किसी को हर कोई
किसी को फुल कॉन्फिडेंट के साथ मैनपुलेट
कर पाता है। तो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की जो
नीव है या जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स है
उसकी जो क्वालिटी ही क्या है वो है
कॉन्फिडेंस। वो वो है आपका कॉन्फिडेंस। तो
नाउ बिफोर एन अटैक डिफाइन द प्रोसेस एंड द
फ्रेमवर्क। मतलब कहने का मतलब क्या है? कि
अटैक करने से पहले हमें एक प्रॉपर प्रोसेस
ऑफ फ्रेमवर्क को डिफाइन करना पड़ता है।
अगर हम ऐसा नहीं करते विदाउट ए प्रॉपर
प्रोसेस एंड फ्रेमवर्क वी कैन लैंड इन ए
सीरियस ट्रेवल कैन से सीवियर डैमेज टू द
मेंटल हेल्थ ऑफ आवर टारगेट अगर हम ऐसा
नहीं करते तो हम क्या कर सकते हमारे साथ
क्या हो सकता है हम बहुत बड़ी मुसीबत में
फड़ सकते हैं कौन सी मुसीबत लीगल मुसीबत
कानून की जो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बात करते हैं हम कानून जो साइबर लॉ है
उसकी जो मुसीबत है उसमें हम फंस सकते हैं
या फिर अगर आप उस प्रोसेस और उस फ्रेमवर्क
को सही तरीके से फॉलो नहीं करोगे। उस
फ्रेमवर्क को सही तरीके से उसको यूटिलाइज
नहीं करोगे। तब भी क्या होगा? आप अपने
टारगेट की मेंटल हेल्थ को भी क्या कर सकते
हो? डैमेज कर सकते हो। और एज यू नो कि जो
प्रीवियस क्लास थी क्लास नंबर 66 हमने कुछ
केस स्टडीज पढ़ी थी। इफ यू रिमेंबर हमने
एक अह रॉयल फैमिली का एक जो वुमेन थी अह
शी वाज़ एडमिटेड इन ए हॉस्पिटल फॉर सम
सीरियस रीज़ंस। शी वाज अ प्रेग्नेंट लेडी
एंड एक जो एक सोशल किसी दो डीजीएस ने उनका
मजाक मतलब कि उनकी जो मेडिकल हिस्ट्री थी
उसको एज ए ऑन एयर ब्रॉडकास्ट कर दिया था।
तो उसकी वजह से क्या हुआ था कि जो
रिसेप्शनंस पे नर्स थी उसने शी अटेम्प्ट ए
सुसाइड। तो ऑलरेडी हमें पता है कि कितनी
सीवियर चीज़ हो सकती है। किसकी अह मेंटल
हेल्थ पर कितना इफ़ेक्ट पड़ सकता है। कितना
सोशल प्रेशर पड़ता है? ये सारी चीजें हम
ऑलरेडी डिस्कस कर चुके हैं। तो अनप्लान
अटैक्स लीड टू लीगल एकशंस एंड अरेस्ट। अगर
आप बिना प्लान के अटैक करोगे तो क्या हो
सकता है? आपके ऊपर लीगल एकशंस लिए जा सकते
हैं। आप अरेस्ट भी हो सकते हो। मतलब आपको
प्रॉब्लम मुसीबत का सामना करना पड़ सकता
है। ओके? नेक्स्ट टारगेटेड एक्सपीरियंस,
स्ट्रेस, एंग्जायटी एंड इमोशनल ट्रॉमा।
ओके? और जो
उसकी वजह से क्या हो सकता है? किसी भी
व्यक्ति को स्ट्रेस हो सकता है, ए्जायटी
हो सकती है या इमोशनल ट्रामा से वो फेस
करना पड़ सकता है। बिकॉज़ ऑफ योर सिंगल
मिस्टेक एंड लैक ऑफ स्ट्रक्चर डिस्ट्रॉयड
ट्रस्ट एंड कम्युनिटी रेपुटेशंस। अगर आपने
उस स्ट्रक्चर को फॉलो नहीं किया, उस
प्रोसेस को फॉलो नहीं किया जिसकी वजह से
क्या होता है कि जो ट्रस्ट है और जो
कम्युनिटी की रेपुटेशंस है वो भी बहुत
सारी डैमेज होती है। तो बेसिकली हम क्या
कर सकते हैं? बिल्कुल हम एक क्लियर और
एथिकल फ्रेमवर्क का यूज़ करते हैं। जस्ट हम
पहले अपना ऑब्जेक्टिव डिफाइन करते हैं।
स्कोप एंड बाउंड्री डिस्कस करते हैं।
प्रोफाइलिंग करते हैं। प्लान स्ट्रेटजी
स्ट्रेटजी बना। उसके बाद एक और फिर
अप्रूवल हमारे पास होना चाहिए। एथिकली हम
एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं। फिर उसके बाद
डॉक्यूमेंट एंड रिपोर्ट करते हैं। जिससे
और उसके बाद फाइनल में हम क्या करते हैं?
डी ब्रीफ एंड इंप्रूवमेंट। हमें क्या-क्या
डी ब्रीफ और इंप्रूवमेंट करना चाहिए। सारी
चीजें हम क्या करते हैं? किसी भी प्रोसेस
में करते हैं। ये एक सिंपल प्रोसेस है। तो
नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट विद ए
अब हम स्टार्ट करते हैं। जो हमारा क्लास
का रोड मैप क्या रहेगा? दो दिन का रोड मैप
है। इसमें कुछ चीजें ऐड भी होंगी तो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं। हम उसको इसमें हाईलाइट
नहीं करते। तो हमारे जो कोर्स के टॉपिक
क्या है? हम बात करने वाले हैं स्कोपिंग
प्रोसेस क्या रहेगी? स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क
क्या होता है? रूल ऑफ इंगेजमेंट या फिर हम
बात करते हैं एक होता है इंटरनल एंप्लॉय
या ई एंड ओ इंश्योरेंस। मतलब यह क्या चीज
होती है? इसके बारे में हम डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं आज के क्लास में और कल की क्लास
में। उसके बाद क्या है क्सक्वेंसेस ऑफ़
पुअर स्कोपिंग व स्कोपिंग इंगेजमेंट फेल
एंड दी स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट एंड डिफाइनिंग
असेसमेंट ऑब्जेक्टिव सेलेक्टिंग मेथड्स
एंड टेक्निक्स एंड बिल्डिंग इफेक्टिव सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग प्रिटेक्स्ट मतलब इन पे हम
डिस्कशन करने वाले हैं जो टॉपिक हम कवर
करने वाले हैं आज और कल की क्लासेस में तो
उसके बाद लर्निंग आउटकम क्या रहेगा अब
इससे आपको क्या-क्या सीखने को मिलेगा हाउ
टू कोऑर्डिनेट प्रोफेशनली विद क्लाइंट
बिफोर एन इंगेजमेंट स्टार्ट इंगेजमेंट
स्टार्ट होने से पहले आप कैसे कोऑर्डिनेट
करोगे। कैसे आप एक प्रोफेशनलिज्म शो करोगे
किसी भी क्लाइंट के साथ वह आप सीखने को
मिलेगा। द पर्पज ऑफ स्टेटमेंट एस ओ
डब्ल्यू एंड रूल ऑफ रूल ऑफ इंगेजमेंट ऑफ
स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क का पर्पज क्या है?
क्यों हमें यह
जरूरत पड़ती है स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क एंड रूल
ऑफ इंगेजमेंट की? व्हाई रिटन ऑथराइजेशन इज़
एसेंशियल फॉर एव्री पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट।
हमें कोई भी पेन टेस्टिंग परफॉर्म करनी
हो, उसके लिए हमें रिटन ऑथराइजेशन की
जरूरत क्यों पड़ती है? यह चीज आपको सीखने
को मिलेगी। द लीगल रिस्क एसोसिएटेड विद
पुअर प्लानिंग एंड अनक्लियर स्कोप। अगर
आपका स्कोप पुअर है, आपका जो स्कोप है,
सही से डिफाइन नहीं है, तो आपको किन-किन
लीगल रिस्क का सामना करना पड़ सकता है?
उसके बाद ई एंड ओ इंश्योरेंस क्या होता
है? और हाउ टू डिफाइन रियलिस्टिक
इंगेजमेंट ऑब्जेक्टिव एंड मेथोडोलॉजीस।
मतलब कौन-कौन सी मेथडोलॉजीस या
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स हम कैसे क्लाइंट के साथ
डिस्कस करना है, क्या नहीं, क्या चीज हमें
डिस्कस करनी है? एंड हाउ प्रोफेशनल सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग प्रिटेक्स्ट आर प्लंड विदाउट
विद इन ऑथराइजिंग इंगेजमेंट। और जब इतनी
सारी चीजें जब डिफाइन होती है, इतनी सारी
चीजों पे बातचीत होती है, उसके बाद हमें
क्या करना है? जो प्रीक्स्ट क्योंकि पूरी
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग प्री टेक्स्ट पे बेस है।
तो उस प्र जो प्री टेक्स्ट है, उसको कैसे
प्लान करना है? इन सारी बाउंड्रीज़ के अंदर
रहते हुए इन सारी किसके अंदर? जो ऑथराइज
इंगेजमेंट्स है मतलब आपको इनस्कोप रहते
हुए अपने प्री टेक्स्ट को कैसे क्या करना
है प्लान करना है तो ये सारी चीजें हमारा
जो क्लास है ये रोड मैप है जो हम कवर करने
वाले हैं हम सीखने वाले हैं तो मे बी सबको
मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही होगी आई होप कि
मुझे पता है आज स्टूडेंट्स बिल्कुल ही
नहीं आए हैं और इट्स ओके मुझे कंटेंट
डिलीवर करना है आई विल डिलीवर माय कंटेंट
आप लोग रिकॉर्डिंग देख लेना अगर आप किसी
भी कारण से नहीं आ पाए क्लासेस में तो
चलिए हम स्टार्ट करते हैं। सबसे पहले
शुरुआत करते हैं हम कोऑर्डिनेटिंग विद द
क्लाइंट। सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट करेंगे
कोऑर्डिनेटिंग विद द क्लाइंट। तो
कोऑर्डिनेटिंग विद द क्लाइंट क्या है ये
चीज? मतलब क्लाइंट के साथ कोऑर्डिनेट
करना। मतलब यह क्या है कि इसमें कुछ
स्टेप्स होते हैं। कुछ स्टेप होते हैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट प्लानिंग। कि
जब आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की इंगेजमेंट करने
वाले हो उसकी प्लानिंग क्या रहेगी? उसमें
कुछ स्टेप्स होते हैं। ये चीजें आपको मेक
श्योर करनी होती है बिफोर ट्राई टू
अटेम्प्ट एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक। तो
कौन-कौन सी सबसे पहले क्लाइंट
कोऑर्डिनेशन, स्कोप डेफिनेशन, पॉइंट ऑफ
कांटेक्ट, टाइम कंसीडरेशन, लीगल
ऑथराइजेशन, साइज ऑफ इंगेजमेंट,
कम्युनिकेशन फ्लो और इंगेजमेंट लाइफ
साइकिल। ये कुछ छह से आठ आपके कुछ स्टेप्स
होते हैं। वन बाय वन वन बाय वन। ओके? सब
नहीं आवाज आ रही होगी आप सबको। तो ये सारी
चीजें तो हम सबसे पहले शुरुआत करते हैं
क्लाइंट कोऑर्डिनेशन एंड स्कोप डेफिनेशन
से। ओके? तो हमें क्या करना है? सबसे पहला
हमारा काम होता है कि अटैक की जो अटैक हम
परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं। कौन सा अटैक
परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं हम? सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। तो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की के
अटैक करने से पहले या उसके जो प्रिपरेशन
करने से पहले जो सबसे पहला रूल क्या होता
है हमारा वो होता है क्लाइंट के साथ
कोऑर्डिनेट करना। मतलब अब क्लाइंट कोई भी
हो सकता है। क्लाइंट क्लाइंट में कौन-कौन
हो सकता है? आपको पैसे देने वाला कोई
कस्टमर आपका क्लाइंट हो सकता है। आपका
ऑफिस मैनेजर आपका क्लाइंट हो सकता है। या
आपकी कंपनी में ही कोई दूसरी इंटरनल टीम
है वह भी आपका क्लाइंट हो सकता है।
बेसिकली आपको अगर कोई पैसे दे रहा है वह
भी आपका क्लाइंट है या कोई आपका सीनियर
आपका जैसे कि सुपरवाइजर्स या आपका जो
मैनेजर्स है वह भी क्लाइंट ही है। अगर वह
आपको पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए बोल रहा है या
फिर एक कंपनी है। एक कंपनी के अंदर दूसरी
थर्ड पार्टी कंपनीज़ है। टीम्स ऑपरेट कर
रही हैं। अगर वो आपको टेस्टिंग के लिए बोल
रही हैं वो भी आपके क्या हो सकते हैं?
क्लाइंट हो सकते हैं। और आपको एक बात एक
बात हमेशा ध्यान में रखनी है। क्या चीज
ध्यान में रखना है कि स्कोपिंग प्रोसेस
अब आपकी जो भी स्कोपिंग प्रोसेस है। ठीक
है? इसको हम बाद में डिस्कस करेंगे
क्योंकि अभी आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा। तो
हम चलो स्कोपिंग पे बात करते हैं हम सबसे
पहले। ठीक है? क्लाइंट कोऑर्डिनेशन का
मतलब क्या होता है कि आपको क्या करना है?
जो क्लाइंट है आपका उसके आमने-सामने बैठकर
क्या डिसाइड करना है आपको? इस इंगेजमेंट
की प्रिपरेशन करनी है। मतलब जो आपका
क्लाइंट है उसके साथ आमने-सामने बैठकर
आपको डिस्कस करना है। इन स्कोप, आउटर
स्कोप आपको क्या करना है? आमने सामने उसके
बैठकर पूरा रोड मैप तैयार करना है। ठीक
है? कि इंगेजमेंट कैसे चलाना है? कैसे आप
इंगेजमेंट को चलाओगे? आप क्या चाहते हो?
और इसमें हम क्या-क्या डिसाइड करते हैं?
वो सारी चीज़ बात करेंगे। इसमें हम डिसाइड
करते हैं स्कोप में कि टारगेट क्या-क्या
होगा? एक्टिविटीज कौन से कैसे-कैसे
परफॉर्म करने हो? आपके बाउंड्रीज क्या है?
रूल ऑफ इंगेजमेंट। सारी चीजें आप डिस्कस
करते हो आमने-सामने बैठकर आप क्लाइंट के
साथ कि आपके इन स्कोप क्या रहेगा? आउट ऑफ
स्कोप क्या है? कि आप क्या-क्या नहीं कर
सकते? और इन स्कोप में आप क्या-क्या कर
सकते हो? यह सारी चीज़ आप क्या करते हो?
ड्यूरिंग क्लाइंट कोऑर्डिनेशन एंड स्कोप
डेफिनेशन। तो, स्टेप वन, स्टेप टू क्या हो
गए? सबसे पहले आप क्या करते हो? अपने
क्लाइंट से मिलते हो। उसके साथ मीटिंग
सेटअप करते हो। मीटिंग सेटअप करने के बाद
उसके साथ आप डिस्कशन स्टार्ट करते हो।
डिस्कशन स्टार्ट में सबसे पहले क्या होता
है? स्कोप डिफाइन होता है। स्कोप की
डेफिनेशंस डिफाइन होता है। तो ये चीज थी
आपकी कौन सी? क्लाइंट कोऑर्डिनेशन एंड
स्कोप डेफिनेशन। नेक्स्ट अब आते हैं हम
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट। ठीक है? अब हमें
डिसाइड क्या-क्या करना है। कुछ कि ऐसा तो
नहीं कि आप उनके साथ बैठ गए। ठीक है? और
उसके बाद डायरेक्टली आपने कुछ नहीं किया।
आपको आपका जो क्लाइंट है वह आपको सब कुछ
बताएगा। नहीं डिस्कशन में क्या-क्या करना
है? सबसे पहले आप ध्यान दे सकते हो पॉइंट
ऑफ कांटेक्ट कि पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट मतलब हु
विल बी आवर मेन पर्सन इन द कंपनी हु विल
नो दैट द टेस्ट इज इन प्रोग्रेस। मतलब
कंपनी में हमारा मेन बंदा कौन होगा या मेन
पर्सन कौन होगा या मेन व्यक्ति कौन होगा
जिसको पता होगा कि टेस्टिंग चल रही है।
कंपनी में ऐसा तो कोई व्यक्ति होगा। कोई
ना कोई ऐसा
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट होगा जिसको यह चीज पता
होगी कि कंपनी में पेन टेस्टिंग चल रही है
या पेन टेस्टिंग चलने वाली है या टेस्टिंग
चलने वाली है। ठीक है? और एंड द पीओसी इज
द प्राइमरी रीजन इन द प्राइमरी पर्सन इन द
कंपनी हु इज अवेयर दैट द इंगेजमेंट इज इन
प्रोग्रेस। मतलब वही है कि पॉइंट ऑफ
कांटेक्ट वही पहला बंदा होगा जिसको यह पता
है। उसको जिसको इस चीज के बारे में
अवेयरनेस है। जिसको इसके बारे में पता है
कि इंगेजमेंट प्रोग इन प्रोग्रेस है या
आपके जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग होने वाली है
कंपनी पे हम टेस्टिंग करने वाले हैं। ठीक
है? रोल्स एंड रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज क्या होती
है? पीओसी पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट की एक्ट एट द
मेन कम्युनिकेशन ब्रिज बिटवीन द टेस्टिंग
टीम एंड द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। उसका मेन मोटो
क्या है? कि जो टेस्टिंग टीम होती है और
जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है उसके बीच में एक ब्रिज
का काम करता है कम्युनिकेशन पास करने के
लिए। मतलब अगर मुझे मुझे कोई भी प्रॉब्लम
हुई, मुझे कोई भी डाउट आया, मुझे कुछ भी
पूछना है या कुछ बताना है तो मैं क्या
करूंगा? अपने पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट से बात
करूंगा। पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट क्या होगा? वो
कंपनी में फिर अपने सुपीरियर्स है, सीनियर
अथॉरिटीज है उनसे बात करेगा। नाउ प्रोवाइड
इंटरनल इनेशन, अप्रूवल्स एंड क्लीयरेंस एज
नीडेड। और उसको जिन-जिन पेन टेस्टिंग करने
के लिए जिन-जिन चीजों की उसको जरूरत है
जैसे उसको किसी चीज का अप्रूवल चाहिए कोई
क्लेरिफिकेशन चाहिए या कोई इंटरनल
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए अगर
दे सकता हो तो तो वो कैसे पेंटेस्टर किसके
साथ डील करेगा? पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट के साथ।
एस्केलेट इश्यूज इंसिडेंट और ब्लॉकर्स
ड्यूरिंग द इंगेजमेंट। यह सारी चीजें
रोल्स एंड रिसोंसिबिलिटी किसकी होती है?
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट की। इंश्योर इंटरनल टीम
आर अवेयर ऑफ द टेस्ट टू अवॉयड फॉल्स अलर्ट
ऑन डिसेप्शन। और ये इसकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
है कि जो शॉक टीम होगी ठीक है? कि उसके
पास आप वाइट लिस्टेड हो कि अभी उनको
डिटेक्ट नहीं हुआ अलर्ट वो बात अलग है।
लेकिन अदरवाइज उनको वाइट लिस्ट किया जाएगा
क्योंकि उनको पता होगा जो इंटरनल टीम होगी
शॉक वाली जो सिक्योरिटी मॉनिटरिंग टीम
होती है कि हां यहां पर टेस्टिंग होने
वाली है। टेस्टिंग चल रहा है। तो यह चीज
क्या है? आप अलर्ट मतलब अगर अलर्ट आता भी
है तो उसको आप क्या करना है? रिपोर्ट करना
है। इग्नोर करना है। व्हाटएवर जो चीज
पॉलिसी के अकॉर्डिंग आप डील करने वाले हो
या जो आप अपने क्लाइंट के साथ कोऑर्डिनेट
करने वाले हो। किस टाइप की पेन टेस्टिंग
चाहते हैं? उसके हिसाब से वो चीज क्या
करोगे? आप किसके साथ डिस्कस करोगे? पॉइंट
ऑफ कांटेक्ट के साथ। मे बी यू अंडरस्टैंड
कि पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट क्या हो गया? तो
इसलिए आप कह सकते हो जो आपका पॉइंट ऑफ
कांटेक्ट होगा वो प्राइमरी कांटेक्ट होगा।
ठीक है? चाहे आप प्राइमरी कांटेक्ट बोल
सकते हो, बैकअप कांटेक्ट बोल सकते हो,
इमरजेंसी कांटेक्ट मतलब आपको अगर कांटेक्ट
करना है, अगर आपको कोई डाउट है, आपको कोई
सवाल पूछना है या फिर आपको कुछ भी लगता है
कि मुझे यह चीज हेल्प चाहिए रिगार्डिंग टू
द कंपनी टेस्टिंग। तो वो क्या करेगा? आप
डायरेक्टली किससे डील करोगे? पॉइंट ऑफ
कांटेक्ट के साथ। तो, सबसे
पहली चीज आपको क्या करना है? अपने पॉइंट
ऑफ कांटेक्ट के बारे में डिस्कस करना है
ड्यूरिंग दिस कोऑर्डिनेशन मीटिंग दिस
मीटिंग दिस प्लानिंग प्रोसेस जो इंगेजमेंट
की प्लानिंग प्रोसेस में आपको क्या करना
है पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट के बारे में डिस्कस
करना है देन उसके बाद क्या है टाइमिंग
कंसीडरेशन उसके बाद आता है टाइमिंग
कंसीडरेशन कि हाउ मच टाइम इज एलोकेटेड फॉर
दिस पेनिशन टेस्ट कि इस पेन टेस्ट के लिए
कितने घंटे मिले हैं हमें कितना टाइम दिया
गया है कितने टाइम पेन टेस्टिंग कंप्लीट
करने है। कितने घंटे हमें अलोकेट किए?
मतलब हाउ मेनी हावर्स आर अलॉटेड फॉर दिस
पन टेस्ट? इस पेंट टेस्ट के लिए कितने
घंटे हमें अलॉट किए गए हैं? कितने घंटे
में यह पेंटेस्ट हमें कंप्लीट करना है?
शुड कॉल शुड कॉल्स एंड सोशल इंजर्स
अटेम्प्ट टू मेड ड्यूरिंग द डे। क्या यह
हमें दिन में कॉल करना है या अह रात में
कॉल कर सकते हैं? यह भी आप डिस्कस करो।
शुड कॉल सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटेम्प्ट टू बी
मेड या नाइट में? मतलब क्या सोशल को हम
नाइट में कर सकते हैं? नहीं कर सकते हैं,
डे में करना है, नहीं करना है। ये सारी
चीजें आप क्या करते हो? डिस्कस करते हो
किसकी? आपके क्लाइंट के साथ। एंड शुड
टेस्टिंग बी परफॉर्म्ड ऑन वीक डेज और
वीकेंड्स। क्या ये टेस्टिंग आपको वीक डेज
में करनी है या वीकेंड्स में करनी है। यह
सारी चीजें आप क्या करते हो?
टाइम कंसीडरेशन के पॉइंट पर आप बात करते
हो कि पहली बात कितने दिन है मेरे पास इस
पेन टेस्टिंग की रिपोर्ट सबमिट के लिए या
कितने घंटों में मुझे पेन टेस्टिंग
कंप्लीट करनी है। दूसरी क्या ये पेंटे
मुझे दिन में करनी है नाइट में करनी है या
फिर मुझे वीक डेज में करनी है मंडे टू
फ्राइडे या वीकेंड्स में करनी है ये सारी
चीजें। उसके बाद नेक्स्ट चीज होती है
ब्लैकआउट पीरियड। नेक्स्ट चीज होती है
आपकी ब्लैकआउट पीरियड। ब्लैकआउट पीरियड
होता क्या है? दीज़ आर स्पेसिफिक डेट्स और
हावर्स व्हेन यू आर स्ट्रिक्टली
प्रोहिबिटेड फ्रॉम परफॉर्मिंग एनी
टेस्टिंग एक्टिविटीज। ब्लैक आउट पीरियड
कौन सा होता है? यह वो स्पेसिफिक डेट्स या
घंटे होते हैं जिसमें आपको टेस्टिंग करने
की स्ट्रिक्ट मनाही होती है। रिस्ट्रिक्शन
होता है। मतलब आप उस टाइम फ्रेम में उस
दिन या उस टाइम ड्यूरेशन में आप पेन
टेस्टिंग परफॉर्म नहीं कर सकते। क्योंकि
रीजन हो सकता है कोई प्रोडक्ट ल्च होने
वाला है, कोई फाइनेंसियल क्लोजिंग होने
वाली है, इंटरनल ऑडिट चल रहा है या कोई
एग्जीक्यूटिव मीटिंग चल रही है या कुछ
सिस्टम का मेंटेनेंस विंडो है। जिस टाइम
पे आप क्या नहीं कर सकते? पेन टेस्टिंग
नहीं कर सकते। मतलब आपको ब्लैकआउट पीरियड
के बारे में भी डिस्कशन करना है। उस किसके
दौरान? इस प्लानिंग प्रोसेस के दौरान।
ओके? इस प्लानिंग प्रोसेस के दौरान।
नेक्स्ट आपको क्या करना है?
लीगल लैंग्वेज मतलब लीगल लैंग्वेज मतलब
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट मस्ट कंटेन लीगल लैंग्वेज दैट
प्रोटेक्ट यू एंड योर इंगेजमेंट मतलब जो
आप कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन करोगे जब आप क्लेंट
के साथ डिस्कशन करोगे डिस्कस करने के बाद
जो आपका कॉन्ट्रैक्ट बनेगा जो आपका स्कोप
डिफाइन होगा उसमें ऐसी लीगल लैंग्वेज होनी
चाहिए जो आपको प्रोटेक्ट करे ठीक है जो
आपको प्रोटेक्ट करे एंड यह कैसे पॉसिबल बल
है। यह तभी पॉसिबल है जब आप क्या करने
वाले हो?
जब आप लॉयर के साथ बैठकर
क्या करने वाले हो? यह चीजें डिस्कस
करोगे। क्योंकि जब भी आप कोई भी बड़े
प्रोजेक्ट होते हैं कंपनी के हैं, उसमें
हमेशा एक लॉयर होता है। लॉयर को हमेशा लूप
लूप में रखा जाता है। फॉर लार्ज प्रोजेक्ट
ऑलवेज कीप ए लॉयर इन लूप। लीगल रिव्यु
इंश्योर द कॉन्ट्रैक्ट इज़ फेयर, क्लियर
एंड प्रोटेक्ट यू फ्रॉम अननेसेसरी। मतलब
आप अगर आप लॉयर को इंक्लूड करते हो अगर
बड़ा प्रोजेक्ट है ज्यादा बड़ी पेन
टेस्टिंग है या ज्यादा महंगा प्रोजेक्ट है
तो उसमें आप एक लॉयर का रखना इट इज ए वेरी
गुड प्रैक्टिस बिकॉज़ वो क्या होगा
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट हमेशा आपके फेयर में रहेगा
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट क्लियर रहेगा और अननेसेसरी से
आपको क्या करेगा प्रोटेक्ट करेगा दूसरी
क्या चीज है दूसरी क्या है प्रोटेक्ट
अगेंस्ट अनफोर्सिंस इवेंट्स मतलब कि कॉन
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट मस्ट इंक्लूड एक्ट्स ऑफ गॉड
एंड अनफोर्सिन सरकमस्ट्ससेस क्लोज सो दैट
इफ समथिंग गोज़ रोंग बियों्ड योर कंट्रोल
यू आर नॉट हेल्ड रिस्पांसिबल मतलब कि जो
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट बनेगा कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में एक्ट
ऑफ गॉड का भी क्लोज होना चाहिए जैसे
अर्थक्वेक हो गया फ्लड हो गया या अनफोर्स
अनफोर्सिन सरकमस्ट्ससेस मतलब ऐसे
सरकमस्ट्ससेस जो हमारे परे हैं जो अनफॉगल
है ठीक है जैसे पावर आउटेज हो गया
पेंडेमिक स्टम फायर या कुछ और भी ऐसे
इवेंट्स जो हमारे कंट्रोल में नहीं है वह
भी आपके कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में इंक्लूड होने
चाहिए क्योंकि क्यों होने चाहिए बिकॉज़
ताकि अगर कल को कुछ ऊपर नीचे हो भी गया
कुछ गड़बड़ हो भी गई तो क्या हो आप पर बात
ना आए आप क्या कर लो लीगली प्रोटेक्ट हो
ठीक है मतलब एक्ट ऑफ गॉड हो गया अनफोर्स
इन सरकमस्ट्ससेस ठीक है या लिमिटेशन
लायबिलिटी िटी यह सारी चीजें आपके उसमें
कांटेक्ट में होनी चाहिए ताकि आपको क्या
रहेगा यह सारी चीजें
आपको प्रोटेक्ट कर पाए मतलब जो लीगल
लैंग्वेज है वो मैक्सिमम आपके फेवर में
होनी चाहिए ठीक है पूरी फेवर में नहीं हो
सकती लेकिन ऐसी होनी चाहिए कि कुछ अगर ऊपर
नीचे होता है कुछ प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट होती है
तो आप उससे बच जाए तो नेक्स्ट हमारा क्या
है नेक्स्ट है साइज ऑफ इंगेजमेंट
साइज ऑफ इंगेजमेंट मतलब यह भी डिस्कस करना
है कि
हमें टोटल कितने फीसिंग ईमेल भेजने की
परमिशन है। मतलब हम कितने फीसिंग ईमेल भेज
सकते हैं? कितनी विसिंग कॉल कर सकते हैं?
कितने इंडिविजुअल्स को हम टारगेट कर सकते
हैं? कौन-कौन से डिपार्टमेंट्स को कौन-कौन
से लोकेशनेशंस को हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
टारगेट कर सकते हैं? ये सारी चीजें हमें
क्या करनी है? क्लाइंट के साथ डिस्कस करनी
है। वी डिफाइन एंड गेट ऑथराइजेशन फॉर द
स्केल ऑफ आवर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
एक्टिविटीज। मतलब आप कितनी फॉर एग्जांपल
आप 500 ईमेल भेज सकते हो, 100 कॉल कर सकते
हो, 250 यूज़र्स को टारगेट कर सकते हो। तीन
ही डिपार्टमेंट को टारगेट कर सकते हो। यह
सारी चीजें आपको क्या करनी है? साइज ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट के अंदर आपको डिस्कस करनी है
आपके क्लाइंट के साथ। मतलब जो जो चीजें
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं कि क्लाइंट के
आमने-सामने बैठकर आपको यह सारी चीजें
डिस्कस करनी है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
स्टार्ट करने से पहले। इसीलिए जो आज का
चैप्टर है इसका नाम है प्रिपेयरिंग फॉरेन
अटैक। अटैक की तैयारी। अटैक की तैयारी में
बहुत सारी चीजें होती है। डायरेक्ट आप कभी
भी अटैक नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि आपके पास
कुछ भी लीग लीगल अथॉरिटी नहीं है। और लीगल
अथॉरिटी कब तैयार होती है? जब आप जो आपसे
पेन टेस्टिंग करवाना चाहता है, वह क्या
है? आपका क्लाइंट है। तो उस क्लाइंट के
साथ आप बैठकर सारी चीजें डिस्कस करनी है
कि पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट है, टाइम कंसीडरेशन
हो गया, लीगल लैंग्वेज हो गई, साइज ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट। देन उसके बाद आ गया आपका
कम्युनिकेशन फ्लो। कम्युनिकेशन फ्लो क्या
है कि एक स्ट्रक्चरल अह वह हो गया आपका
स्ट्रक्चरल फ्लो होगा जिसमें आप क्या कर
सकते हो कि पहले क्लाइंट है प्रोजेक्ट फिर
उसके बाद प्रोजेक्ट मतलब आपकी चेन ऑफ
कमांड क्या रहेगी? बेसिकली अगर आप कुछ भी
आपको कम्युनिकेशन करना है तो आप सबसे पहले
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट तो है ही। अगर आपको कुछ
चीज़ रिपोर्ट करनी है तो वो किस फॉर्मेट
में वो चीजें होंगी? चेन ऑफ़ कमांड क्या
रहेगी? सबसे पहले क्लाइंट है। उसके बाद
प्रोजेक्ट मैनेजर आता है। फिर लीड पेंट
टेस्टर आता है। उसके बाद असेसमेंट टीम आ
गई। डेली स्टेटस अपडेट एग्जीक्यूटिव
स्टेटस मीटिंग होगी। फिर फाइनल रिपोर्ट।
मतलब ये कम्युनिकेशन फ्लोर भी पूरा डिफाइन
होना चाहिए। उसके हिसाब से आप क्या करते
हो? अपनी रिपोर्ट भी डिजाइन करते हो। उस
हिसाब से आप अपनी रिपोर्ट भी डिजाइन करते
हो। तो जो चीज हमने डिस्कस की वो सारी
चीजें क्या है आपकी? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
इंगेजमेंट प्लानिंग का एक हिस्सा है। हमने
क्या-क्या चीजें डिस्कस की? क्लाइंट
कोऑर्डिनेशन, स्कोप डेफिनेशन, पॉइंट ऑफ
कांटेक्ट, टाइम कंसीडरेशन, लीगल
ऑथराइजेशन, साइज ऑफ इंगेजमेंट क्या रहेगा?
उसके बाद कम्युनिकेशन फ्लो क्या रहेगा?
इंगेजमेंट लाइफ साइकिल मतलब जो टाइम
कंसीडरेशन के अंदर मतलब यह जो आपको एक
इमेज दिखाई दे रही है आपके सामने। यह इमेज
जस्ट आपको लग रहा होगा कि इसमें कुछ बॉक्स
बने हुए हैं और कुछ भी नहीं। लेकिन आज की
क्लास में जितने भी इमेजज़ हैं, हर एक इमेज
अपने आप में इंडिविजुअल टॉपिक है।
इंडिविजुअल एक कांसेप्ट है इंडिविजुअल
इंफॉर्मेशन है या आपको हर एक स्लाइड को आप
क्या कर सकते हो जब सेव करोगे अगर उसका
स्क्रीनशॉट भी लेते हो तो हर एक स्लाइड
में बहुत ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन है ताकि अगर
उसको आप गो थ्रू करोगे उस इसके अंदर जो भी
कुछ लिखा है वो आप पढ़ो भीगे ना आपको
बिल्कुल क्रिस्टल क्लियर हो जाएगा कि
चीजें इसमें क्या लिखी हुई है कि इसका
मतलब क्या हो सकता है क्योंकि हमने यहां
पर डिस्कस कर लिया डिस्कशन के बाद जो अगर
आप स्लाइड्स हैं उनको गो थ्रू भी करोगे इस
इमेज को गो थ्रू भी करोगे तो उसमें वह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन लिखी है जो आपको ध्यान
रखनी है। इट इज़ वेरी वेरी क्रिटिकल
इंफॉर्मेशन। इट इज़ वेरी वेरीेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन जो आपको मिस आउट नहीं करनी है।
एक और चीज है अगर आपका स्कोप भले ही खत्म
भी हो गया हो। ठीक है? आपका स्कोप खत्म हो
गया। स्कोपिंग प्रोसेस कंप्लीट हो गई। ठीक
है? और अगर आप काम कर रहे हो, आपने पेन
टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट कर दी। और अगर आपको कोई
भी डाउट आता है तो आपको हमेशा सवाल पूछने
हैं। सवाल पूछने में हिचकिचाना नहीं है।
क्यों? क्योंकि बात यहां पर आपकी रोजी
रोटी की है। आपके क्रिमिनल रिकॉर्ड की है।
अगर आप डाउट में रहोगे तो हो सकता है कि
जो चीज नहीं करनी थी वह चीज आपने कर दी।
तो इसलिए आपको क्या करना है? आपको अगर
थोड़ा सा भी डाउट आता है। आपको लगता है कि
मुझे चीज समझ में नहीं आ रही या मुझे इस
पे डिस्कशन कर लेना चाहिए। इस पे मुझे
सवाल पूछ लेना चाहिए। तो सवाल पूछ ही लेना
चाहिए। बिकॉज़
यहां पर आ गई बात आपकी जॉब सिक्योरिटी की।
आपकी रोजी रोटी की।
ओके? तो, यह चीज आपको ध्यान रखना है।
अदरवाइज आप पे क्या होगा? लीगल एक्शन हो
जाएंगे। आपका पेन टेस्टिंग करियर वहीं पर
खत्म हो जाएगा। तो, नेक्स्ट आते हैं हमारे
टॉपिक है हमारा स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क। एस ओ
डब्ल्यू एंड रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट।
स्टेटमेंट ऑफ रोल एंड रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट।
तो नाउ वंस द स्कोपिंग प्रो स्कोपिंग
डिस्कशन इज कंप्लीट दी एंटायर एग्रीमेंट
इज डॉक्यूमेंटेड एज पार्ट ऑफ द
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट एंड इज कॉल्ड एज स्टेटमेंट ऑफ
वर्क। एक बार क्या हुआ? एक बार आपने क्या
किया? आपका जो स्कोपिंग प्रोसेस थी। जो
स्कोपिंग डिस्कशन था जो आप क्लाइंट के साथ
बैठकर डिस्कस कर रहे थे। एक बार वह
कंप्लीट हो गया। वह डिस्कशन पूरा हो गया।
उसके बाद क्या करते हो आप? जो जो चीजें
डिस्कस हुई हैं। वह सारी चीजों क्या करते
हो आप एक डॉक्यूमेंट के फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट
करते हो उसको एक डॉक्यूमेंट के फॉर्म में
उसको कॉन्ट्रैक्ट बनवाते हो ठीक है
बेसिकली आप उसको क्या बोलते हो एक
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट बनवाते हो वो जो जो चीजें
आपने डिस्कशन की आपकी लीगल लीगल लैंग्वेज
की बात हुई टाइम फ्रेम की बात हुई या फिर
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट की बात हुई कम्युनिकेशन
फ्लो क्या होगा इन स्कोप आउट स्कोप जो भी
चीजें हुई उसके ऊपर आप क्या करते हो वह
उसके ऊपर एक डॉक्यूमेंट उसको एज ए
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट क्या करते हो उसको बनवाते हो
उसमें कन्वर्ट करते हो और जिस चीज को हम
क्या बोलते हैं स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क जो
डॉक्यूमेंट बनेगा जो डॉक्यूमेंट वो रेडी
होगा उसको हम क्या बोलते हैं स्टेटमेंट ऑफ
वर्क एस ओ डब्ल्यू इसमें क्या होगा दी
स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क क्लियरली डिफाइन व्हाट
यू आर ऑथराइज्ड टू डू एंड व्हाट यू आर नॉट
ऑथराइज्ड टू डू ये जो कॉन्ट्रैक्ट है ये
जो स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क है इसमें साफ-साफ
लिखा होगा कि आप क्या कर सकते कर सकते और
क्या नहीं कर सकते मतलब क्या ऑथराइज हो
क्या ऑथराइज नहीं हो तो व्हाट इज
स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क स्टेटमेंट ऑफ़ वर्क क्या
है ए फॉर्मल डॉक्यूमेंट दैट आउटलाइन द
स्कोप ऑब्जेक्टिव रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज
डिलीवरीबल एंड रूल्स अंडर व्हिच द
इंगेजमेंट विल बी परफॉर्म्ड मतलब यह वो एक
फॉर्मल डॉक्यूमेंट होता है जिसमें आपका
स्कोप डिफाइन होता है। आपका ऑब्जेक्टिव
डिफाइंड होता है। आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज़
डिफाइंड होती है। आपके रूल्स डिफाइंड होते
हैं। या आपको क्या करना है, क्या डिलीवर
करना है, क्या डिलीवर नहीं करना। यह सारी
चीजें आपके स्कोप ऑफ वर्क में डिफाइन की
जाती है। इवन आपका जो रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट
होता है, वह आप किसके अंदर आता है? आपका
स्कोप ऑफ
वर्क के अंदर आता है। मतलब स्टेटमेंट ऑफ
वर्क के अंदर आता है। आपका जो रूल्स ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट है, वह भी किसके अंदर आता है?
आपका
आर ओई जिसको हम बोलते हैं किसके अंदर आपका
स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क के अंदर आता है। तो
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा स्टेटमेंट ऑफ
वर्क क्या होता है कि स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क
में क्लियर कट लिखा होता है कि आप क्या
करने के लिए ऑथराइज हो और क्या करने के
लिए अन ऑथराइज्ड हो। अब रूल्स ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट में हम बात करते हैं। रूल्स ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट में बहुत ज्यादा डिटेल्ड
इंफॉर्मेशन लिखी हुई है। जैसे कि
प्रीक्स्ट रिलेटेड कि कौन सा प्रीटेक्स्ट
यूज़ करना है। प्रीक्स्ट सिनेरियो जैसे कि
क्लियरली डिफाइन व्हिच प्रीक्स्ट आर अलाउड
व्हिच आर रिस्ट्रिक्टेड। कौन सा
प्रीटेक्स्ट आप यूज़ कर सकते हो? कौन सा
प्रीक्स्ट आप यूज़ नहीं कर सकते। दूसरा कौन
सा वि सोर्स मेल और आईपी एड्रेस स्पेसिफाई
द सोर्स ईमेल एड्रेस और आईपी एड्रेस दैट
विल बी यूज्ड फॉर टेस्टिंग मतलब कौन सी
सोर्स ईमेल आप यूज कर सकते हो या कौन सा
आईपी एड्रेस आप यूज कर सकते हो पेन
टेस्टिंग के लिए कौन से डेजिग्नेशन आईपी
एड्रेस या टारगेट आप यूज़ कर सकते हो फॉर
पेन टेस्टिंग या आपकी लिमिटेशंस क्या है
आपकी बाउंड्रीज क्या है आपका ब्लैकआउट
पीरियड्स क्या है या किस टाइम पर आपकी
एक्टिव एक्टिविटी जो है वो स्ट्रिक्टली
प्रोहबिटेड है। मतलब उस टाइम फ्रेम में आप
ये चीजें नहीं कर सकते। उसके बाद आपकी
रिपोर्टिंग एंड कम्युनिकेशन मतलब आपका
रिपोर्टिंग चैनल क्या है? ठीक है? आपके
इमरजेंसी कांटेक्ट क्या है? ये सारी चीजें
आपकी किस में हो जाती है? रूल्स ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट के अंदर। ठीक है? और सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट बात होती है जो आपको ध्यान में
रखनी है कि यह वाली जहां पर मैं आपको
स्टार मार्क करके दे रहा हूं।
सबसेेंट पॉइंट इस कोने में आपको दिखाई दे
रहा होगा कि स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क और
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में आपका नाम मेंशन होना
चाहिए। एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स
एज ए टेस्टर्स आपका नाम साफ-साफ मेंशन
होना चाहिए। योर नेम एज अ टेस्टर मस्ट बी
क्लियरली मेंशंड इन द स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क
एंड कांटेक्ट। मस्ट है। यह चीज होना ही
होना चाहिए। एंड कंपनी नेम मस्ट बी
मेंशंड। अगर आप किसी कंपनी के लिए काम कर
रहे हो तो उस कंपनी का नाम भी उसके अंदर
मेंशन होना चाहिए। या फिर
ऑल टेस्टर्स इनवॉल्व इन द इंगेजमेंट मस्ट
बी लिस्टेड विद द फुल नेम्स। या आप किसी
कंपनी में काम कर रहे हो तो आप अकेले तो
काम नहीं कर रहे हो। आप एक टीम वर्क में
काम कर रहे हो। एक टीम के साथ काम कर रहे
हो। उस टीम में जितने भी टेस्टर्स हैं या
इस टेस्टिंग के लिए उस कंपनी के जितने भी
टेस्टर्स इनवॉल्व है उन सबका नाम यहां पर
होना चाहिए क्योंकि दिस प्रोटेक्ट यू
लीगली इफ एनी इशू अराइज़ यू कैन शो दिस
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट एज योर लीगल ऑथराइजेशन। अगर
कल को कुछ इशू हो भी गया कुछ प्रॉब्लम
क्रिएट होगी तो आप क्या कर सकते हो कि यह
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट शो कर सकते हो कि ओके ओके वी
आर ऑथराइज हमें ऑथराइज किया था कंपनी ने
यह हमारे नाम है यह हमारी कंपनी का नाम है
या एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स यह मेरा नाम है तो
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में 100% आपका नाम होना ही
चाहिए ओके आपका कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में नाम होना
चाहिए अगर कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में आपका नहीं है
तो फिर आप एंड टेस्टिंग मत करना। बिकॉज़ कल
को अगर कंपनी ने क्लेम कर दिया या किसी ने
क्लेम कर दिया कि अन ऑथराइज्ड टेस्टिंग तो
आपके पास कोई भी सबूत कोई भी प्रूफ नहीं
होगा कि
आप ने टेस्टिंग क्यों की? किसके कहने पर
की? क्योंकि आपको प्रोटेक्ट करने वाला कोई
नहीं होगा।
समझ में आ रहा है सबको?
आपको चीज समझ में आ रही है गाइस?
आपको ये चीज समझ में आई?
नेक्स्ट हम बात करते हैं अभी।
अब यह जो ऑथराइजेशन की बात हो रही है रिटन
ऑथराइजेशन की जिसको हम ऑडिट ट्रायल भी बोल
सकते हैं। ठीक है? वो इतना ज्यादा जरूरी
क्यों है? व्हाई इट इज एसेंशियल? ठीक है?
वह इतना जरूरी क्यों है? नाउ इमेजिन ए
सिनेरियो। आप एक सिनेरियो सोचिए। ठीक है?
यहां पर जितने भी बॉक्स हैं, जो भी चीजें
यहां पर लिखी हुई है, हर एक चीज पूरी
डिटेल में लिखी हुई है। आप खुद से पढ़ोगे,
सारी चीजें समझ में आ जाएंगी। मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन करता हूं और काफी डिटेल नॉलेज
है आपके सामने। तो चलिए देखो फॉर एग्जांपल
आप किसी कंपनी के के लिए काम करते हो। आप
उसके क्या कर रहे हो? एक परमानेंट इंटरनल
एंप्लॉय हो। आप किसी कंपनी में एक
परमानेंट इंटरनल एंप्लॉय हो। ठीक है? और
जब आप किसी कंपनी के इंटरनल एंप्लॉय हो तो
आपके पास मैनेजर आया और मैनेजर ने आपको
बोला लेट्स डू ए डमी फिशिंग टेस्ट ऑन आवर
ओन एंप्लॉय टुमारो। चलो एक काम करते हैं
कि अपने ही एंप्लॉय का एक डमी फिशिंग
टेस्ट लेते हैं। आपके मैनेजर ने आपको
बोला। ठीक है? तो मेरा सवाल यह है विल यू
स्टार्ट विदाउट थिंकिंग? क्या आप बिना
सोचे समझे पेन टेस्टिंग शुरू कर दोगे?
क्या बिना सोचे समझे आप पेन टेस्टिंग
स्टार्ट कर दोगे? क्या वह डमी जो टेस्ट के
लिए आपका जो मैनेजर आपको बोल रहा है क्या
वह टेस्टिंग आप स्टार्ट कर दोगे? बिल्कुल
नहीं। आपको वो टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट नहीं करनी
है। ठीक है? अगर आप इंटरनल एंप्लई भी हो
तब भी आपको
पूरे ऑथराइजेशन के साथ इन रिटर्न मतलब
आपको ऑथराइजेशन चाहिए वो भी रिटर्न में
ओरल नहीं कहने से कुछ नहीं होता। आपको ओरल
परमिशन नहीं आपको रिटन परमिशन चाहिए वह
टेस्टिंग करने के लिए। क्योंकि जो ओरल
परमिशन होती है अह जो हम जिसको हम बोल
सकते हैं कि आपके एंप्लॉय ने बोला कि चलो
कल पेन टेस्टिंग करते हैं। वो कोई भी मैटर
नहीं करती। ठीक है? वो कभी भी काम नहीं
करती और उसका कोई भी महत्व नहीं है। ठीक
है? इवन एज एन इंटरनल एंप्लॉय यू मस्ट गेट
कंप्लीट ऑथराइजेशन इन राइटिंग नेवर वर्क
ऑन ओरल परमिशन। मतलब भले ही आप इंटरनल
एंप्लई ही क्यों ना हो। अगर आपका मैनेजर
आपको बोलता है चलो पेन टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट
कर कल एक डमी टेस्ट करते हैं तो आपको उसके
कहने पर आपके ओरल परमिशन पर या उसके बोलने
पर 10 टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट नहीं करनी है।
आपको तब भी एक प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन एक प्रॉपर
आपको हो सकता है कि कंपनी में किस टाइप का
सिस्टम यूज़ होता है। अगर ऑनलाइन सिस्टम
टिकटिंग सिस्टम फॉर एग्जांपल कोई
सॉफ्टवेयर है उसमें टिकट रेज़ करते हैं।
उसमें फिर एक अथॉरिटी है। एक चैनल्स है।
उस चैनल में अप्रूव होने के बाद वो आपके
पास आता है। फिर आप लीगल लीगली क्या है वो
दिखा सकते हो। आपके पास ईमेल आई है या
आपके पास कुछ आपने एक डॉक्यूमेंट साइन
किया है उसके लिए। तो जब तक वो चीजें नहीं
हो जाती तब तो आपको क्या करना है वो पेन
टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट नहीं करनी है। ओके?
बिकॉज़ क्योंकि क्योंकि जो ओरल परमिशन है
ठीक है? वो आपका ऑडिट वो क्या होती है?
आपका ऑडिट ट्रायल नहीं है। ठीक है? नाउ
कंपेयर हम करते हैं ओरल परमिशन वर्सेस
ऑडिट ट्रायल। ओरल परमिशन क्या है कि फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर मैनेजर ने आपको ओरली बोला
ठीक है और आपने फिशिंग टेस्ट करना शुरू कर
दिया। मैनेजर ने आपको बोला और आपने फिशिंग
टेस्ट स्टार्ट कर दिया। देन कोई भी एक फॉर
एग्जांपल उसके बाद किसी बड़े एंप्लई कोई
सीओई ले लो आप या सीओ ले लो या फिर आप कोई
भी मैनेजमेंट
मैनेजमेंट टीम से हो गया। ठीक है? उसने
क्या किया? कंप्लेन कर दी। ठीक है? तो उस
केस में क्या होगा? मैनेजर कैन इजीली
डिनाई वी वो क्या बोल सकता है? वी मस्ट
डिस्कस द आईडिया हु आस्क यू टू डिप्लॉय इट
लाइव। मतलब क्या है कि मैनेजर ने सीधा
अपनी बात से पलट गया। मैनेजर ने बोला कि
मैंने तो सिर्फ डिस्कस किया था। तुम्हें
लाइव डिप्लॉय करने के लिए किसने बोला? एंड
इट बिकम्स योर वर्ड अगेंस्ट। इट बिकम्स
योर वर्ड अगेंस्ट देयर। मतलब
आपके उसके शब्द ही क्या हो गया? अभी आपके
अगेंस्ट यूज़ हो गए। समझ में आ गया? मतलब
आप हार गए। आप प्रूव ही नहीं कर पाओगे।
इसीलिए रिटर्न पर अगर रिटर्न परमिशन होती
जिसको हम ऑडिट ट्रायल भी बोल सकते हैं।
ठीक है? तो आप आपका जो मैनेजर था वो डिनाई
कर ही नहीं सकता। मना ही नहीं कर सकता
क्योंकि आपके पास एक पीस ऑफ पेपर, एक ईमेल
या वह टिकट होगी जिसमें आपको ऑथराइज किया
गया था कि यह टेस्टिंग करनी है। ठीक है?
तो व्हाट इज ऑडिट ट्रायल? अब ये ऑडिट
ट्रायल होता क्या है? यह ऑडिट ट्रायल होता
क्या है? ठीक है? तो ऑडिट ट्रायल इज अ
सिंपल टर्म। इट इज़ द चेन ऑफ़ एविडेंस दैट
हेल्प यू टू वेरीफाई एनी एक्शन स्टेप बाय
स्टेप। तो अगर ऑडिट ट्रायल को अगर सिंपल
मतलब सिंपल भाषा में समझे तो ये एक चेन ऑफ
एविडेंस है जिससे कोई भी पुरानी बात या
एक्शन को स्टेप बाय स्टेप वेरीफाई किया जा
सकता है। मतलब
इसकी हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हो? आपने
जो भी काम किया, क्यों किया? किसके कहने
पर किया? ठीक है? यह चीज आप साबित कर
पाओगे विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए ऑडिट ट्रायल इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड कॉर्पोरेट वर्ल्ड
व्हेन एनी इशू अकर्स ऑडिट ट्रायल इज व्हाट
प्रोटेक्ट यू। ठीक है? जो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी है जो कॉर्पोरेट वर्ल्ड है
उसमें अगर कोई इशू हो भी गया तो ऑडिट
ट्रायल हमेशा आपकी जान बचाने के लिए है ना
कि आपको फंसाने के लिए। मतलब
इसको एग्जांपल से समझते हैं कि यू रन ए
फिशिंग टेस्ट एज एज पर मैनेजर्स
इंस्ट्रक्शन एंड बाय मिस्टेक द कंपनीज मेल
सर्वर्स इज ब्लॉक्ड फॉर 2 हावर्स। ठीक है?
मान लो मैनेजर के कहने पर आपने फिचिंग
टेस्ट रन किया और गलती से कंपनी का मेन
ईमेल सर्वर 2 घंटे के लिए ब्लॉक हो गया।
इन दैट केस क्या हुआ? आईटी डायरेक्टर आया।
आईटी डायरेक्टर ने पूछा हु डिड दिस टेस्ट
एंड हु ऑथराइज इट? कि यह किसकी गलती है और
यह टेस्ट किसने किया? तब बात आती है
वेरिफिकेशन की। जब यह सवाल पूछा गया यहां
पे आती है वेरिफिकेशन की बात पॉइंट नंबर
फोर पर। एंड इस केस में इफ यू हैव रिटन
परमिशन। आपके पास ऑडिट ट्रायल है देन आप
क्या बोल सकते हो? आप कह सकते हो आई डिड
नॉट डू दिस ऑन माय ओन। आई वाज ऑथराइज्ड।
मैंने यह खुद से नहीं किया। मुझे ऑथराइज
किया गया था। और आप क्या करोगे? आप अपना
ईमेल या जो आपने जिस डॉक्यूमेंट या जिस
प्रोसेस के तहत आपने वो टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट
की थी, आप उसको दिखाओगे। हम एग्जांपल लेते
हैं कि कंपनी में क्या कर रहा है? एक
टिकटिंग सिस्टम है। स्टेप वन कि मैनेजर ने
एक टिकट रे की मंडे को मतलब रिक्वेस्ट की।
ट्यूसडे को जो आईटी हेड थे उसने उसको
अप्रूव किया, अप्रूवल दिया और वेडनेसडे को
एज ए पेंटेस्टस आपने उस पे एक्शन लिया।
बिकॉज़ आईटी हेड ने उसको अप्रूव किया है।
मैनेजर ने उसको रेज किया है। मतलब दिस
स्टेप बाय स्टेप डिजिटल रिकॉर्ड्स इज
कॉल्ड ऑडिट ट्रायल। यह जो स्टेप बाय स्टेप
डिजिटल रिकॉर्ड्स हैं, इन्हीं को हम बोलते
हैं ऑडिट ट्रायल। और इनसे यह साफ प्रूफ हो
जाता है कि आपने कोई अनअथराइज्ड काम नहीं
किया बल्कि आप सिर्फ अपना काम कर रहे थे
जिसका पूरा ट्रैक रिकॉर्ड मौजूद है जिसके
पूरे सबूत अवेलेबल्स हैं आपके पास बिकॉज़
यू आर ए ऑथराइज्ड पर्सन आपने कुछ भी अपनी
मर्जी से नहीं किया इन दैट केस अगर वहीं
पर इफ इट वाज़ ओनली ओरल परमिशन मतलब आपके
पास रिटन परमिशन नहीं है सिर्फ ओरल परमिशन
है। फॉर एग्जांपल
कि आपने बोला कि सर मैंने तो मैनेजर सर
मैनेजर ने चाय पीते वक्त बोला था कल टेस्ट
कर लेना। ठीक है? नाउ मैनेजर नाउ कैन नाउ
से वी जस्ट डिस्कस द आईडिया। आई नेवर सेड
टू डिप्लॉय इट लाइव। अब मैनेजर यह भी बोल
सकता है कि सर यह तो मैंने बस आईडिया
डिस्कस किया था। मैंने लाइव बोल लाइव
डिप्लॉय करने के लिए थोड़ी ना बोला था।
अब इस केस में क्या है?
आपके पास कोई भी सबूत नहीं है। आप यह
जस्टिफाई ही नहीं कर पाओगे। यू हैव नो
प्रूफ। आपके शब्द आप ही के खिलाफ हो गए।
आप आर्गुममेंट हार गए। पूरा ब्लेम आपके
ऊपर आ गया। बिकॉज़ आपके पास कोई भी रिटर्न
परमिशन नहीं थी।
दैट इज व्हाई एज एन एंप्लई
आपको क्या करना? हमेशा रिटर्न परमिशन
चाहिए होती है। ठीक है? अब तीन बेनिफिट
होते हैं ऑडिट ट्रायल के। देयर आर टॉप
थ्री बेनिफिट्स ऑफ ऑडिट ट्रायल। सबसे पहले
बेनिफिट क्या होता है? अकाउंटेबिलिटी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी। इट कैन क्लियरली शोज़ हु
अप्रूव्ड, व्हाट व्हेन एंड अप टू व्हाट
एक्सटेंट।
इससे बिल्कुल साफ हो जाता है।
अकाउंटेबिलिटी सबसे पहली बात बेनिफिट कौन
सा? अकाउंटेबिलिटी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी। यह
जिम्मेदारी जिसको हम बोलते हैं इससे
बिल्कुल साफ हो जाता है कि किसने किस चीज
की परमिशन दी, कब दी और किस हद तक दी।
नेक्स्ट नॉन रेपुडिएशन कैन नॉट डिनाई मतलब
इनकार नहीं कर पाना। ऑडिट ट्रायल है अगर
आपके पास वह सबूत है तो फिर आप का जो
मैनेजर है, आपका जो बॉस है, वह मना नहीं
कर पाएगा। वंस एन ईमेल और टिकट इज
अप्रूव्ड नो वन कैन डिनाई इट लेटर बाय
सेइंग आई नेवर सेड दैट एक बार आपके पास वो
ईमेल या वो अप्रूवल आ गया तो कल को कोई
आपकी प आपकी पेंटस्टी में कुछ गड़बड़ भी
होगी तो जिसने आपको बोला था वो मुकर नहीं
सकता कि मैंने ऐसा करने को नहीं कहा मतलब
वो डिनाई नहीं कर सकता। थर्ड चीज क्या है?
लीगल प्रोटेक्शन। इन केस ऑफ लीगल
इन्वेस्टिगेशन कोर्ट्स एंड ऑडिटर्स
एक्सेप्ट ओनली रिटर्न टाइम स्टैंप
रिकॉर्ड्स एज प्रूफ नॉट ओरल स्टेटमेंट्स
अगर कल को मामला बहुत ज्यादा सीिवियर हो
गया गंभीर हो गया लीगल इन्वेस्टिगेशन हो
गई तो जो कोर्ट होता है जो ऑडिटर्स होते
हैं वह सिर्फ आपके जो रिटर्न और जो टाइम
स्टिक जो रिटर्न रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं आपके
जो टाइम स्टैंप रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं उन्हीं
को सच मानते हैं। मुंह बोली बातों को कभी
भी वह सच नहीं मानते। इसीलिए
आपको
जस्ट एक कहने पर पेन टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट
नहीं करनी है। आपको कहने पर पेन टेस्टिंग
स्टार्ट नहीं करनी है। आपको प्रॉपर रिटर्न
ऑथराइजेशन चाहिए। अभी मैं आपको बताता हूं
कि रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन क्या होता है? रिटर्न
ऑथराइजेशन नॉट जस्ट परमिशन बट डिफाइन
स्कोप।
ठीक है? इट इज मोर देन जस्ट परमिशन। जो
आपका जो रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन होता है वो
सिर्फ परमिशन नहीं होती बल्कि वह स्कोप भी
होता है। ठीक है? रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन
इंक्लूड बोथ परमिशंस एंड स्कोप। जो रिटर्न
ऑथराइजेशन है उसमें एक तो परमिशन होती है।
दूसरी उसके अंदर स्कोप भी होता है। दोनों
चीजें डिफाइन होती है रिटर्न आपके रिटर्न
ऑथराइजेशन में। फॉर एग्जांपल कि
पेन टेस्टिंग में कौन-कौन से डिपार्टमेंट
टारगेटेड है? कौन-कौन से डिपार्टमेंट में
आप टारगेट कर सकते हो? कौन सा डोमेन आपको
यूज़ करना है? कौन सा डोमेन यूज़ नहीं करना?
टाइम और ड्यूरेशन है, टेस्टिंग चैनल क्या
रहेगा? किन-किन को छोड़ना है? कितने किस
टाइप का टैग आप यूज़ कर सकते हो? क्या-क्या
आपकी लिमिटेशंस है? रिपोर्टिंग
कम्युनिकेशन प्रोसेस। जब आप रिटन
ऑथराइजेशन लोगे तो उसमें क्या होगा? स्कोप
डिफाइन किया जाएगा। एक तो परमिशन मिलेगी।
दूसरा स्कोप डिफाइन किया जाएगा। जब आपके
पास स्कोप होगा तो मतलब फिर तो आपको पता
ही है लीगल लीगल चीजें क्या करनी है।
व्हाई स्कोप इज क्रूशियल? अब यह जो स्कोप
है वो इतना इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है? क्योंकि
इफ स्कोप इज नॉट क्लियरली डिफाइंड एंड द
कंपनी मेल सर्वर गेट ब्लैकलिस्टेड और
इंपैक्टेड द फुल ब्लेम विल बी ऑन यू। अगर
आपके पास स्कोप डिफाइंड नहीं है और कम कल
को कंपनी का मेल सर्वर ब्लैकिस्टेड हो गया
या कंपनी में कोई आपकी वजह से इशू हो गया
सिस्टम क्रैश हो गया कुछ भी हो गया तो
पूरा ब्लेम किसके ऊपर आएगा आप पर आएगा ना
कि जिसने आपको बोला था इसीलिए रिटर्न
ऑथराइजेशन होगा तो उसमें स्कोप भी डिफाइन
होगा और स्कोप अगर स्कोप डिफाइन होगा तो
अगर ड्यूरिंग टेस्टिंग अगर अगर आपने आउट
ऑफ स्कोप कुछ भी नहीं किया है तो उससे
क्या होगा?
आप प्रोटेक्टेड रहोगे। लीगली भी और एथिकली
भी। अगर आउट ऑफ स्कोप आपने कुछ किया है
देन यू आर नॉट प्रोटेक्टेड। भले ही आपके
पास रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन हो। अगर आपके पास
रिटन ऑथराइजेशन
नहीं है तो फिर आपको कोई प्रोटेक्ट नहीं
कर सकता। लेकिन अगर आपके पास रिटर्न
ऑथराइजेशन है तो उसमें स्कोप 100% होगा।
अब स्कोप डिफाइंड है और आपने इन स्कोप
टेस्टिंग की है और उसकी वजह से कल को कुछ
भी हो भी गया तो आप वो सीधा वो आपका जो
रिटर्न परमिशन है आपका एक आपका प्रोटेक्शन
की तरह काम करेगा वो जस्ट एक पेपर वो एक
ईमेल या वो सिस्टम जो आपके लिए सबूत
इकट्ठे करेगा कि आपने कुछ भी गलत काम नहीं
किया है। इसलिए हमेशा रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन
लें। ठीक है? स्कोप के अंदर काम करें। ठीक
है? स्कोप को फॉलो करें। ठीक है? और कोई
भी आउट ऑस्कोप वाला काम ना करें। अभी हम
बात करते हैं आपके इंटेंट और एक्शन की।
इंटेंट और एक्शन मतलब आपकी नियत अच्छी थी
पर कानून क्या कहता है? योर इंटेंट इज गुड
बट व्हाट ड लॉ से? इंटेंट मतलब नियत अच्छी
है आपकी। एक्शन मतलब अब कानून क्या बोलता
है? तो बात करते हैं आपके इंटेंट। योर
इंटेंट टू फाइंड वनेबिलिटीज एंड हेल्प द
कंपनी टू इंप्रूव देर सिक्योरिटी एंड द
व्हाट लॉ द लॉ लुक एट वेदर यू हैड
ऑथराइजेशन और नॉट मतलब साइबर सिक्योर जो
साइबर लॉ है उनमें बिल्कुल
सीधा और सिंपल क्लियर लिखा हुआ है उनका
सीधा और सिंपल मतलब है या जो कानून है
उसका सीधा सिंपल मतलब यह है उनका सीधा
वसूल क्या है या सीधा और सिंपल
बहुत ही इजी एक असूल है। वो असूल क्या है
कि कानून आपकी नियत नहीं देखता। आपका
ऑथराइजेशन देखता है। कानून को आपके इंटेंट
से कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता कि आपका इंटेंट
क्या था। उनको ऑथराइजेशन चाहिए। आपके पास
परमिशन थी या नहीं। इफ यू टेस्ट विदाउट
ऑथराइजेशन इवन विद गुड इंटेंट दे लॉ
कंसीडर यू एज अन ऑथराइज्ड अटैकर।
अगर आप बिना परमिशन के किसी सिस्टम को
टेस्ट कर रहे हो चाहे आपका गोल आपका जो
इंटेंट है वह सिर्फ वनेबिलिटी ढूंढकर
कंपनी को बचाने के लिए ही क्यों ना हो।
मतलब आप आप सोच रहे थे कि ठीक है एक काम
कर लेते हैं टेस्टिंग कर लेते हैं और
कंपनी को सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइड करते हैं
कहीं हमारी कंपनी का लॉस ना हो जाए। आपका
इंटेंट अच्छा था। बट कानून की नजर में वह
अन ऑथोराइज्ड अटैकर है। बिकॉज़ क्योंकि
आपके पास वह करने की परमिशन नहीं थी। और
जब बात आती है अन ऑथराइज्ड अटैक की तो
अकॉर्डिंग टू इंडियन कॉन्टेक्स्ट आईटी
एक्ट 200 टेस्टिंग विदाउट एक्सप्लसिट
परमिशन कैन अट्रैक्ट सिविल एंड क्रिमिनल
लायबिलिटीज अंडर द आईटी एक्ट 200 मतलब
सेक्शन 43 डैमेज टू कंप्यूटरटर्स कंप्यूटर
सिस्टम्स एटसेट्रा सिविल लायबिलिटी एंड
सेक्शन 66 कंप्यूटर रिलेटेड ऑफेंसेस
क्रिमिनल लायबिलिटी मतलब यह है कि अगर आप
बिना बिना किसी एक्सप्लसिट परमिशन के
टेस्टिंग कर रहे हो तो सेक्शन 43 के
अकॉर्डिंग डैमेज टू कंप्यूटर या कंप्यूटर
सिस्टम्स एंड सेक्शन 66 कंप्यूटर रिलेटेड
ऑफेंसेस के तहत आपको सिविल और क्रिमिनल
लायबिलिटीज आ सकती हैं। मतलब आपके जो
सिविल है या जो क्रिमिनल्स की जो धाराएं
हैं वह आप पे लग सकती हैं। और इससे क्या
करना पड़ सकता है आपको? या तो इसमें या तो
फाइन का भी प्रोविजन है इवन जेल तक का
प्रोविजन एकिस्ट करता है। एंड अकॉर्डिंग
टू ग्लोबल कॉन्टेक्स्ट यूनाइटेड स्टेट
सीएफएफए सीएफए कंप्यूटर फ्रॉड एंड अब्यूज
एक्ट एक्सेसिंग ए कंप्यूटर विदाउट
ऑथराइजेशन इज ए क्रिमिनल ऑफेंस। मतलब कि
अगर बिना किसी ऑथराइजेशन के आप किसी
कंप्यूटर को एक्सेस कर रहे हो और
अकॉर्डिंग टू ग्लोबल कॉन्टेक्स्ट मतलब
इंटरनेशनल लॉ तो आप क्या हो एक क्रिमिनल
ऑफेंस करने वाले हो मतलब आप क्या कर रहे
हो एक
अन ऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस कर रहे हो अन ऑथराइज्ड
एक्टिविटी आप परफॉर्म कर रहे हो और यह जो
है यह क्या है
यह क्या है आपके अगेंस्ट आपके ऊपर इन लॉ
के अकॉर्डिंग लीगल एकशंस परफॉर्म किए जा
सकते हैं। जस्ट फॉर एग्जांपल विदाउट
सिस्टम जनरेटेड अप्रूवल और रिटर्न बैकअप
योर डिफेंस ऑफ आई वाज डूइंग इट फॉर कंपनी
गुड इज यूज़लेस इन कोर्ट और बिफोर
इंगेजमेंट। मतलब जब तक आपके पास रिटर्न
अप्रूवल नहीं है तब तक आप कोर्ट या
मैनेजमेंट के सामने यह कहना कि मैंने तो
कंपनी के भले के लिए किया था। यह बिल्कुल
बेबुनियाद है। बिल्कुल बेअसर है। यह काम
नहीं आने वाला।
यह काम नहीं आने वाला। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
समझ में आया
कि आपके इंटेंट और एक्शंस दोनों अलग-अलग
चीजें हैं। ठीक है? आपका इंटेंट कैसा भी
रहा हो। अगर आपके पास ऑथराइजेशन नहीं है
तो डोंट डू एनी अन ऑथराइज्ड एक्टिविटीज।
मतलब आपके पास वो चीज टेस्ट करने का अगर
परमिशन है नहीं अगर आपको टेस्ट आपको किसी
ने बोला नहीं है टेस्टिंग के लिए तो देन
उसको मत करो। अदरवाइज
आपको पता ही है। मैंने आपको हिंट दे दिया।
सेक्शन 43, सेक्शन 66 ऐसे बहुत सारे आईटी
आईटी लॉ एक्सिस्ट करते हैं जो आपको पढ़ने
चाहिए या फिर ग्लोबल लॉ इंटरनेशनल लॉ जो
शायद आपने सुने भी नहीं होंगे और जो आपको
पता भी नहीं चलेगा और अचानक से फंसने के
बाद हमें पता चलता है कि कानून के कौन-कौन
सी धाराएं कौन-कौन से सेक्शंस हम पे लगे
हैं और काश मैं पढ़ लेता। काश मैं अवेयर
होता। काश मैं ये चीजें नहीं करता। तो
कास्ट के चक्कर में पड़ने के बजाय मैटर यह
रहेगा कि जो काम करो प्रोपोथराइजेशन के
साथ करो
ताकि कल को आपको कोई प्रॉब्लम आए कल को
आपके करियर की बात आए कहीं पर वाट लगने
वाली हो तो भैया आप बच जाओ या फिर आप सेफ
रहो ठीक है सामने वाला भी फिर आपके साथ
जाए नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं हम एक चीज और
होती है ठीक है इसके अलावा अब हम बात करते
हैं कंसील एक अब हम बात करते हैं कि जो
कंसलटेंसी फर्म्स होती है उनके पास एक
इंश्योरेंस होता है जिसे हम कहते हैं
एरर्स एंड ओमिशन ई एंड ओ इंश्योरेंस जो
कंसलटेंसी फर्म्स होती है ना उनके पास एक
इंश्योरेंस होता है कौन सा इंश्योरेंस
होता है ई एंड ओ एरर्स एंड ओमिशंस
इंश्योरेंस
अब सबसे पहले हम समझते हैं जो कंसलटेंसी
फर्म्स क्या होती हैं या वह कंपनियां होती
हैं जो किसी स्पेसिफिक फील्ड में एक्सपर्ट
होती हैं और
किसी दूसरी कंपनीज को उनकी प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व
करने के लिए या तो एडवाइस देती हैं या फिर
क्या करती है? उनके लिए एक्सपर्ट लेवल का
काम करने के लिए हायर की जाती है। मतलब जो
दूसरी कंपनी है उनकी प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व करती
हैं या फिर उनको एडवाइस देती हैं या फिर
जो कंसलटेंसी फर्म्स हैं जो थर्ड पार्टी
कंपनीज़ हैं जो अपने फील्ड में माहिर हैं,
एक्सपर्ट हैं, इनको हायर किया जाता है
एक्सपर्ट लेवल का काम करने के लिए। और
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में अगर
हम इसको समझें तो हर एक कंपनी कंपनी के
पास अपनी खुद की एडवांस हैकिंग या पेन
टेस्टिंग टीम नहीं होती। जैसे कि आपके कुछ
बैंक बैंकिंग होंगे, कुछ हॉस्पिटल्स होंगे
या कुछ ई-कॉमर्स साइट होंगी जिनके पास
अपनी खुद की कोई पेन टेस्टिंग टीम नहीं
है। वह क्या करती हैं? वो
बाहर की जो एक्सपर्ट कंपनीज होती हैं उनको
पैसा देती हैं। पैसा देकर बुलाती हैं।
कहती हैं कि आओ हमारे सिस्टम्स को लीगली
हैक करो, चेक करो कि इसमें कोई कमी तो
नहीं है। ठीक है? और इन्हीं एक्सपर्ट
कंपनीज़ को हम बोलते हैं
साइबर सिक्योरिटी कंसलटेंसी फर्म। इन्हीं
एक्सपर्ट कंपनीज़ को हम क्या बोलते हैं?
साइबर सिक्योरिटी कंसलटेंसी फर्म्स। इन
साइबर इनको बोलते हैं। तो इसलिए जो
कंसलटेंसी फर्म्स है इनके पास एक
इंश्योरेंस होता है जिसका नाम क्या है?
एरर्स एंड ओमिशन इंश्योरेंस। अब ये होता
क्या है? ठीक है? यह भी हम बात करने वाले
हैं। उससे पहले मैं आपको बताता हूं कि
इसको एक चीज और बोला जाता है। दो चीजें और
आल्सो नोन एज पीआईआई एंड पीएलआई।
प्रोफेशनल
इंडमेंटी इंश्योरेंस या फिर प्रोफेशनल
लायबिलिटी इंश्योरेंस भी बोला जाता है या
ई एंड ओ इंश्योरेंस तीन नाम ई एंड ओ
इंश्योरेंस या फिर इसको हम पीआईआई भी
बोलते हैं या फिर हम बोल सकते हैं पीएलआई
पर्सनल लायबिलिटी इंश्योरेंस क्या करता है
यह
क्या करता है प्रोवाइड फाइनेंसियल
प्रोटेक्शन व्हेन ए क्लाइंट क्लेम योर
वर्क कॉज देम फाइनेंसियल लॉस ड्यू टू
एरर्स और
मतलब क्या करता है कि अगर एरर्स और एमिशंस
की वजह से [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कोई इशू क्रिएट हो गया। अब यह एरर्स और
एमिशंस जो टर्म्स होती है ओमिशंस इनका
क्या मतलब होता है वो भी हम बात करेंगे।
इनकी वजह से कल को कोई प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हो
भी गई तो आपको फाइनेंशियल प्रोटेक्शन
प्रोवाइड करता है। तो नाउ व्हेन यू
परफॉर्म पेन टेस्टिंग और सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
इन लाइव एनवायरमेंट 1% रिस्क ऑलवेज
एकिस्ट। जब आप एक एथिकल हैकिंग या
या जब कोई भी एक एथिकल हैकर या जो
कंसल्टिंग फर्म होती हैं जब वह लाइव
एनवायरमेंट में पेन टेस्टिंग या सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग करती हैं तो हमेशा 1% रिस्क
तो गलत होने का रहता ही रहता है। 1% रिस्क
रहता ही रहता है कि कुछ ना कुछ गलत हो
सकता है। कुछ ना कुछ गड़बड़ हो सकती है।
कुछ ना कुछ प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हो सकती है।
1% रिस्क हमेशा बना रहता है। ठीक है? चाहे
वो कंसलटेंसी फर्म फर्म उसके ऊपर टेस्टिंग
कर रही हो, चाहे कोई इंडिविजुअल हैकर हायर
किया गया हो, चाहे वो खुद की टीम ही क्यों
ना हो। ठीक है? 1% रिस्क हमेशा एक्सिस्ट
करता ही करता है। जैसे कि मिस्टेक हैपेंस
मतलब
मिस्टेक हैपेंस गलतियां एरर्स। एरर्स हो
सकती है। कैसे? यू रन एन ऑटोमेटेड
वनबिलिटी स्कैन एंड क्लाइंट लेगसी
प्रोडक्शन सर्वर क्रैश। मान लो आपने क्या
किया कि ड्यूरिंग टेस्टिंग आप ऑटोमेटेड
वनबिलिटी स्कैनिंग चलाया। आप वह ऑटोमेटिक
वनबिलिटी स्कैन रन कर रहे थे और वो काम कर
रहा था। और अचानक से क्या हुआ? जो
प्रोडक्शन सर्वर था क्रैश हो गया। जो वो
प्रोडक्शन सर्वर था वो क्रैश हो गया। एंड
जिसकी वजह से क्या हुआ? द बिनेस वाज़ डाउन
फॉर फोर हावर्स एंड द क्लाइंट सफर्ड ए लॉस
ऑफ़ लाख ऑफ। जिसकी वजह से जो 4 घंटे के लिए
उनका सर्वर बंद रहा। बिज़नेस डाउन हुआ।
जिसकी वजह से उनको लाखों रुपए का नुकसान
हो गया। ठीक है? तो यह चांस रहता है। गलती
हो सकती है। बिल्कुल। दूसरा ओमिशन क्या
होता है? मिस्टेक हैपन मिस्टेक बात एरर हो
सकती है। दूसरा अमिशन ओमिशंस क्या होता
है? कि समथिंग गेट मिस्ड। मतलब कुछ छूट
जाए। फॉर एग्जांपल
यू परफॉर्म्ड ए पेन टेस्ट एंड डिलीवर ए
रिपोर्ट दैट एवरीथिंग इज एवरीथिंग इज सेफ।
आपने पेन टेस्टिंग की। आपने कंपनी को
रिपोर्ट फॉरवर्ड कर दी और आपने क्या बोला?
रिपोर्ट में बोला कि सब कुछ सही है। कोई
इशू नहीं है। कंपनी सेफ है। एंड नेक्स्ट
वीक द क्लाइंट वाज़ हिट बाय रेंसमवेयर अटैक
बिकॉज़ ए स्मॉल लूप होल वाज वेस्। और अगले
ही दिन क्या हुआ कि या अगले ही हफ्ते एक
रेंसमवेयर अटैक हो गया कंपनी के ऊपर। और
किसकी वजह से हुआ? एक छोटा सा लूप होल था
जो आप ड्यूरिंग पेन टेस्टिंग मिस कर गए
थे। अब क्लाइंट क्या करेगा? क्लाइंट तो
बोलेगा ही वी पेड यू स्टिल वी वर अटैक।
भैया हमने तो आपको पैसा दिया था फिर भी
अटैक कैसे हुआ? मतलब आपने लापरवाही बरती।
आप सीधा बोलेगा क्लाइंट तो आपको। ठीक है?
तो
अब यहां इंश्योरेंस क्या करता है? या यहां
पर इंश्योरेंस आपको कैसे बचाता है? या फिर
हमें इंश्योरेंस की जरूरत क्यों है? इफ
क्लाइंट फाइल ए सिविल लॉ सूट अगेंस्ट यू
फॉर नेग्लिजेंस दैट कॉज देम फाइनेंसियल
लॉस एंड दिस इंश्योरेंस कवर्स लीगल डिफेंस
कॉस्ट
सेटल एंड जजमेंट कॉस्ट एंड फाइनेंसियल
डैमेज मतलब क्या है कि अगर ड्यूरिंग
टेस्टिंग क्लाइंट का नुकसान हो गया अब वह
आप पर सिविल केस कर देता है तो कोर्ट में
डिफेंस का जितना भी पूरा खर्चा है। ठीक
है? जो भी लीगल डिफेंसेस कॉस्ट है या
सेटलमेंट की बात आ गई या जजमेंट की बात आ
गई या फाइनेंसियल डैमेज की बात आ गई वो
सारी की सारी चीजें क्या करता है? यह
इंश्योरेंस कवर करता है। ठीक है? यह
इंश्योरेंस उस चीज को कवर करता है। इट इज
लाइक अ शील्ड दैट प्रोटेक्ट यू फर्म
प्रोटेक्ट योर फर्म, योर रेपुटेशन एंड योर
फ्यूचर। मतलब यह वो शील्ड की तरह है जो
आपको भी बचाएगा, आपकी फर्म को भी बचाएगा,
आपकी रेपुटेशन को भी बचाएगा और हो सकता है
आपके फ्यूचर को भी बचा ले। ठीक है?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड कि ये चीजें क्या होती है? एरर
एंड ओमिशंस क्या होता है? मतलब इंश्योर
एरर एंड ओमिशंस। इंश्योरेंस क्या होती है?
क्यों जरूरी है? क्यों कंसलटेंसी फर्म के
पास होते हैं? कंसलटेंसी फर्म्स क्या होता
है? अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड?
चलो एक लास्ट टॉपिक और बात करते हैं।
लास्ट चीज और बात करते हैं।
क्सक्वेंसीज ऑफ बैड स्कोपिंग।
ठीक है? क्सक्वेंसी ऑफ बैड स्कोपिंग।
अगर आपकी स्कोपिंग सही नहीं है तो उसके
क्या-क्या क्सक्वेंसेस हैं?
चलिए बात करते हैं। तो एक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में एक पुरानी एक कहावत है। एक
कहानी है। ए बैड स्कैन डैमेज ए सर्वर बट ए
बैड स्कोप डैमेज योर वॉल कैरियर। मतलब
क्या है कि एक बैड स्कैन अगर एक गलत स्कैन
हुआ तो सिर्फ वह सर्वर को डैमेज करेगा।
अगर आपका स्कोप ही स्कोप ही आपका गलत है
तो पूरे के पूरे आपका जो करियर है आपके जो
जॉब है उसको खा जाएगा। आपके पूरे करियर को
खराब कर देगा। अगर एक स्कोप खराब होगा।
बैड स्कैन तो सिर्फ सर्वर को खराब करता है
लेकिन जो बैड स्कोप है वो पूरे आपके होल
कैरियर को खराब कर देता है। तो अभी बात
करते हैं स्कोपिंग इज नॉट जस्ट ए फॉर्म
फिलिंग प्रोसेस। इट इज ए लीगल एंड
टेक्निकल बाउंड्री लाइन। इफ दिस बाउंड्री
इज टोन रॉन्ग डिजास्टर इज गारंटेड। अब
स्कोपिंग सिर्फ ऐसा नहीं है कि एक फॉर्म
है उसको फिल कर दिया। बस वैसी प्रोसेस है
कि फॉर्म फिलिंग प्रोसेस है। बस फॉर्म
लिया उसको भर दिया। स्कोपिंग वह नहीं है।
यह एक लीगल और टेक्निकल बाउंड्री लाइन है।
और अगर यह बाउंड्री गलत खींची गई तो
डिजास्टर होना तय है। अगर यह जो बाउंड्री
लाइन है अगर किसी ने गलत खींच दी तो फिर
डिजास्टर होगा ही होगा। इसको कोई भी अवॉइड
नहीं कर सकता। इफ यू डोंट स्कोप प्रॉपर्ली
व्हाट हैपेंस? फेलियर इन स्कोपिंग क्रिएट
ए मेजर हेडेक फॉर बोथ पार्टीज यू एंड द
क्लाइंट योर इंगेजमेंट बिकम्स अननेसेसरीली
कॉम्प्लेक्स योर टाइम इज वेस्टेड एंड यू
मे इवन एग्जीक्यूट द वर्क इन द रॉन्ग वे
मतलब अगर आपने स्कोपिंग ठीक से नहीं की तो
क्या होगा
फेलियर इन स्कोपिंग स्कोपिंग फेल होगी अब
फेलियर इन स्कोपिंग से दोनों पार्टीज का
बहुत बड़ा नुकसान होता है दोनों पार्टी
कौन-कौन आप और क्लाइंट दोनों को बहुत बड़ा
नुकसान होता है। बहुत बड़े हेडेक से
गुजरना पड़ता है। क्या-क्या? आपकी जो एक
तो इंगेजमेंट है वह बहुत ज्यादा
कॉम्प्लेक्स हो जाएगी। बहुत सारा टाइम
वेस्ट होगा और हो सकता है उस बैड स्कोपिंग
की वजह से आप क्या करो? कोई गलत तरीका या
कुछ गलत चीज जो चीज नहीं करनी थी वह
एग्जीक्यूट कर दो। मतलब आउट ऑफ स्कोप आप
टेस्ट कर दो। जिसकी वजह से भी आपको बहुत
सारी सीवियर चीजें या बहुत सारी पेनल्टीज
का सामना करना पड़े। नाउ व्हाट एग्जैक्टली
हैपेंस व्हेन स्कोपिंग फेल्स। जब एक
स्कोपिंग फेल्स होती है तो एक्चुअल में
होता क्या है? बैड स्कोपिंग डज नॉट जस्ट
मींस टाइम वेस्ट। इट इट्स क्सक्वेंसेस आर
वेरी सीवियर। मतलब
बैड स्कोपिंग का मतलब टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
होता। इसके जो क्सक्वेंसेस हैं, वह बहुत
ज्यादा सीिवियर होते हैं। क्या-क्या हो
सकते हैं? जैसे कि अनक्लियर एसेट्स मतलब
स्कोप क्रिप। इफ यू डोंट क्लियरली डिफाइन
द एग्जैक्ट नंबर ऑफ़ आईपीस, सब डोमेनस, वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस ड्यूरिंग द स्कोपिंग। अगर
आपने एज ए पेंटेस्टर स्कोपिंग के वक्त
एग्जैक्ट नंबर ऑफ आईपीस सब डोमेनस या वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस क्लियर नहीं किए कि कितने
आईपी आपके स्कोप में है? कितने सब डोमेन
स्कोप में हैं? कितने वेब एप्लीकेशन स्कोप
में है। अगर यह चीज आपने क्लियर नहीं की
तो क्या होगा? द क्लाइंट विल से इन द
मिडिल ऑफ़ द प्रोजेक्ट ओ वी हैव वन मोर
स्माल पोर्टल प्लीज चेक दैट टू टू वी पेड
द वॉल इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर। अब क्या होगा कि
क्लाइंट बीच में ही आएगा प्रोजेक्ट के बीच
में और बोलेगा आपको यार हमारा एक छोटा सा
और पोर्टल है। प्लीज इसको और देख लो
क्योंकि हमने आपको पूरी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
टेस्ट करने के लिए पे किया है। अब इससे
होगा क्या? योर टाइम एंड रिसोर्सेज विल बी
डबल। आपका जो टाइम है और जो आपके
रिसोर्सेज हैं, वह क्या हो जाएंगे? वह डबल
हो जाएंगे। बट यू वुड नॉट गेट ए यू वुड
नॉट गेट ए सिंगल एक्स्ट्रा फॉर दैट। और इस
चीज के लिए आपको एक भी पैसा एक्स्ट्रा
नहीं मिलने वाला। दूसरी चीज़ क्या-क्या हो
सकती है? आउट ऑफ स्कोप मतलब लीगल नाइट
मेयर। क्लाइंट फॉर एग्जांपल क्लाइंट गिव
एन आईपी रेंज दैट इज नॉट देयर बट बिलोंग
टू ए थर्ड पार्टी क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर या
वेंडर। फॉर एग्जांपल अब मान लो कि जो
क्लाइंट है उसने गलती से आपको एक ऐसी आईपी
रेंज दे दी जो उनकी नहीं थी बल्कि किसी
तीसरी कंपनी कोई भी थर्ड पार्टी क्लाउड
प्रोवाइडर थे या उनकी कोई वेंडर थी उनकी
थी और आपने क्या किया यू रन ऑटोमेटेड
टेस्ट एंड ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक्स और आपने
क्या किया उनके अगेंस्ट ऑटोमेटेड टेस्टिंग
स्टार्ट कर दी या ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक रन
किया देयर फाइव वाल ब्लॉक्स यू एंड दे कैन
फाइल ए लॉ सूट अगेंस्ट यू फॉर
साइबर अटैक एंड अन ऑथराइज हैकिंग। अब उससे
क्या होगा कि अब जैसे ही आपने वह ऑटोमेटिक
टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट की या ब्रूड फ़ोर्स अटैक
किया उसकी वजह से क्या जो थर्ड पार्टी
कंपनी थी उसकी सिक्योरिटी टीम टीम के पास
चला गया अलर्ट। और उन्होंने क्या किया?
फायर वाल पे आपको ब्लॉक कर दिया और आपके
अगेंस्ट क्या किया? एक केस फाइल कर दिया
कि साइबर अटैक हुआ उनके ऊपर। एक अनथराइज
हैकिंग अटेमप्ट हुआ उनके ऊपर। अब इस केस
में क्या होगा?
अब इस केस में क्या होगा भैया? क्लाइंट
विल वाश देयर हैंड्स ऑफ द मैटर। मतलब जो
क्लाइंट था वह अपने हाथ खड़े कर लेगा और
लीगल केस किस पर होगा? अपर होगा ना कि
क्लाइंट के ऊपर। थर्ड अननोन थर्ड जो रिस्क
है वो क्या है? स्कोपिंग फेल होने का
अननोन रिस्क। मतलब बिजनेस डिरप्शन।
फॉर एग्जांपल आप क्या कर रहे थे? स्कोपिंग
डिस्कस कर रहे थे। और स्कोपिंग करते वक्त
इफ यू डोंट आस्क ड्यूरिंग स्कोपिंग इज
देयर एनी लीगल सिस्टम्स दैट कैन क्रैश विद
हैवी ट्रैफिक और यू रन अग्रेसिव स्कैनिंग
देयर द एंटायर लाइव बिजनेस कैन गो डाउन
मतलब स्कोपिंग करते वक्त अगर आप यह पूछना
भूल गए कि क्या कोई ऐसी लेगसिव सिस्टम्स
है कोई पुराने सिस्टम्स आपके कंपनी के
अंदर है जिनके ऊपर अगर हम हैवी ट्रैफिक रन
करें तो वह फेल हो सकता है, क्रैश हो सकता
है या यह चीज आप भूल गए तो क्या होगा?
आपने क्या किया? यह चीज डिस्कस तो की
नहीं। आपने एग्रेसिव स्कैन रन किया और
क्या हुआ? उनका बिजनेस डाउन हो गया।
सिस्टम क्रैश हो गया। उनका बिजनेस स्टॉप
हो गया। रेवेन्यू लॉस हो गया। तो जिसकी
वजह से क्या होगा? जो क्लाइंट का ट्रस्ट
था, वह पूरी तरीके से टूट जाएगा। ठीक है?
क्लाइंट का ट्रस्ट टूट जाएगा। रेपुटेशंस
डाउन हो जाएगी। इसलिए स्कोपिंग डिजास्टर
को अवॉइड करने के लिए हमेशा आपको क्या
करना है? हर एक डिफाइन एवरीथिंग। हर एक
चीज पूछनी है। कौन-कौन से आईपी रेंज?
डोमेन क्या है? सब डोमेन कौन-कौन से
एप्लीकेशन? एपीआई क्लाउड एसेट। पूछ के
कंफर्म करना है। रिटर्न में लेना है। ठीक
है? अज्यूमशन नहीं करना है। कुछ भी नो
एडिशन, नो सेल्फ डिसीजन। ठीक है? अगर
अनक्लियर है तो उसको कम्युनिकेट करो पहले
ही। तो यह सारी चीजें क्या है? अगर आपकी
स्कोपिंग बैड है, अगर आपकी स्कोपिंग
फेलियर है, आपके आपने स्कोपिंग पे ध्यान
नहीं दिया या आपने जो इनस्कोप है, आउट
ऑस्कोप की जो बातें होती है ना कि आप बग
बाउंट क्यों ना करते हो, कुछ भी करते हो
और आप इनस्कोप आउटस्कोप्स ये सारी चीजें
आप ध्यान नहीं देते। दीज़ आर द
सरकमस्ट्ससेस ऑफ बैड स्कोपिंग। नाउ
सबसे खतरनाक चीज क्या होती है ना?
रेपुटेशन डैमेज। आपकी जो रेपुटेशंस है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बुरी तरीके से डैमेज हो जाएगी। ठीक है?
कैसे? द क्लाइंट विल थिंक यू यू आर
कंप्लीटली अनप्रोफेशनल एंड नॉट वर्थ
वर्किंग विद। मतलब क्लाइंट सोचेगा कि आप
बिल्कुल एकदम अनप्रोफेशनल बंदे हो। आपसे
तो काम करवाना ही बेकार है। दूसरी दूसरी
चीज क्या होगी? दूसरा दूसरा पॉइंट क्या
है? कि साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंडस्ट्री इज़
वेरी स्मॉल।
एवरीवन नोज़ ईच अदर। जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी
इंडस्ट्री है ना वह बहुत छोटी इंडस्ट्री
है अगर आपको नहीं पता हो और यहां पर सब
लोग आपस में एक दूसरे को जानते हैं और अगर
ड्यू टू बैड स्कोपिंग द प्रोजेक्ट गेट
डिलेड द क्लाइंट सिस्टम क्रशेस अगर बैड
स्कोपिंग की वजह से क्लाइंट का प्रोजेक्ट
डिले हो गया या क्लाइंट का सिस्टम क्रैश
हो गया तो वह आपको क्या बोलेगा आप पे एक
स्टैंप मोहर लगा देगा अनप्रोफेशनल और अंडर
प्रिपयर्ड।
ठीक है? मतलब मतलब आप एक अनप्रोफेशनल आदमी
हो। आपको कुछ नहीं पता। एक आपको एक थप्पा
मार के दे देगा। आपको एक टैग दे देगा। ठीक
है? एंड साथ के साथ दे विल टेल अदर कंपनीज़
डोंट गिव देम एनी वर्क। दे डोंट इवन
अंडरस्टैंड द कंपनी रिक्वायरमेंट। साथ के
साथ मार्केट में दूसरी कंपनी को भी बोलेगा
इन्हें काम मत देना। इनको तो कंपनी की
बेसिक रिक्वायरमेंट ही समझ में नहीं आती।
मतलब अब हुआ क्या कि आपकी होगी रेपुटेशन
खराब। आपकी फर्म की रेपुटेशन हो गई खराब।
अब आपको कोई भी काम नहीं देने वाला। ना
आपको कोई प्रोजेक्ट मिलने वाला ना आपको
कोई फ्यूचर है। वंस योर रेपुटेशन इज़
डैमेज्ड इन द मार्केट। नो मैटर हाउ मेनी
बिग सर्टिफिकेट्स यू हैव। नो वन नो वन विल
गिव यू एनी पेनिशन टेस्टिंग प्रोजेक्ट। अब
एक बार आपकी रेपुटेशन डैमेज हो गई तो आपको
दुनिया आपके पास यह मैटर नहीं करता कि
दुनिया कितना भी बड़ी सर्टिफिकेशन हो,
आपने कितनी भी तीर मारे हो, कितना भी कुछ
किया हो आपने आपको पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
प्रोजेक्ट नहीं मिलने वाला। बिकॉज़
रेपुटेशन होगी आपकी डैमेज। तो कोई भी
सर्टिफिकेशन, कोई भी हाई लेवल एजुकेशन फिर
वह मैटर नहीं करती। बिकॉज़ बैड स्कोपिंग ने
आपका करियर पूरी तरह से बर्बाद कर दिया।
नाउ
अब
आप कैसे कर सकते हो स्कोपिंग को परफेक्ट?
उसका अल्टीमेट सेवियर क्या है? स्कोपिंग
वर्कशीट। ठीक है? टू मेक इट इजी एंड
रिपीटेबल। वी यूज़ स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट। इट
एक्ट लाइक ए क्वेश्चनयर दैट हेल्प अस आस्क
द राइट क्वेश्चन। मतलब क्या करता है? इसको
इजी और रिपीटेबल बनाने के लिए हम स्कोपिंग
वर्कशीट का यूज़ करते हैं। मतलब हमारे पास
एक स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट होती है जो हमें सवाल
पूछने में मदद करती है। मतलब कुछ बेसिक
सवाल तो हम पूछे ही पूछेंगे ही। ठीक है?
उस स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट की हेल्प से इट एक्ट
लाइक ए क्वेश्चन एयर। मतलब क्या करती है?
जो स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट है वो एक क्वेश्चन
एयर की तरह होती है। जिसमें आप क्या करते
हो? दिस स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट व्हिच फिल्ड बाय
द क्लाइंट लाइक ए चेक लिस्ट एंड इंक्लूड
सम क्रिटिकल क्वेश्चंस मतलब आप क्या करते
हो कि उस कॉपिंग वर्कशीट को क्लाइंट को
देते हो और क्लाइंट से भरवाते हो जिसमें
कुछ क्रिटिकल सवाल होते हैं। कुछ बेसिक
क्वेश्चंस होते हैं। जैसे व्हाट टू टेस्ट,
व्हाट नॉट टू टेस्ट, व्हेन टू टेस्ट, हाउ
टू टेस्ट एंड इमरजेंसी कांटेक्ट। इस तरीके
के बहुत सारे बेसिक-बेसिक क्वेश्चंस होते
हैं उस स्कोपिंग वर्क वर्क स्पेस वर्कशीट
के अंदर जो आप क्लाइंट को दे देते हो
जिससे क्या होता है कि आपके जो बैड
स्कोपिंग के चांसेस हैं वो कम हो जाते हैं
क्योंकि आप फर्स्ट टाइम पेन टेस्टिंग तो
कर नहीं रहे होंगे आपके पास एक्सपीरियंस
क्या है तो पूरी वर्कशीट आप रेडी रखते हो
लेकिन आपके पास फर्स्ट टाइम है बिल्कुल आप
पहली बार पेन टेस्टिंग करने वाले हो तो जो
आज का मैं आज जो चीजें मैंने आपके साथ
डिस्कस की हैं जो चीजें मैंने आपको बताई
है उन पे आपको क्या करना है गौर करना है।
उनको समझना है। उन पर डिस्कस करना है।
उनको नोट डाउन करना है कि कोई भी पेन
टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट करने से पहले इन चीजों
को तो आपको ध्यान में रखना ही रखना है।
अगर आपको अपने आप को प्रोटेक्ट करना है।
अपने आप के ऊपर आपका करियर बचाना है। आपका
जो रेपुटेशन उसको डैमेज होने से बचाना है।
तो इन सब चीजों को तो आपको ध्यान में रखना
ही होगा। तो आज का टॉपिक इतना ही था। तो
अगर
ओके एक और चीज है हैकिंग स्टार्ट्स विद ए
टर्मिनल एथिकल हैकिंग स्टार्ट विद अ
स्कोपिंग वर्क। इसलिए हमेशा याद रखो कि जो
हैकिंग है वो स्टार्ट तो एक टर्मिनल से
होती है लेकिन जो एथिकल हैकिंग होती है वो
हमेशा स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट से स्टार्ट होती
है। ठीक है? अगर कभी आपका मैनेजर आपको
जल्दबाजी में बोले तो इसलिए उसको समझाओ कि
अगर आपको आपके इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को सेफ
बनाना है तो पहले स्कोप को क्लियर रखें।
ओके? पहले स्कोप को क्लियर रखें। तो अभी
तक हमने डिस्कस किया क्लाइंट कोऑर्डिनेशन
और स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क के ऊपर क्योंकि यह
बहुत ज्यादा क्रिटिकल चीजें हैं। अगर इससे
रिलेटेड आपको कोई कंफ्यूजन, कोई डाउट यू
कैन आस्क मी नाउ।
किसी को कोई सवाल है तो मुझसे पूछ सकता
है।
एनीवन हैव एनी डाउट?
एनीवन हैव एनी डाउट रिगार्डिंग टू द
क्लासेस। किसी को कुछ पूछना है कुछ समझ
में नहीं आया हो
बोर हो गए हो, कुछ भी हो या कुछ आपके
दिमाग में एक्स्ट्रा ऑर्डिनरी सवाल आ रहा
है, वह भी पूछ सकते हो आप।
इट्स ओके फिर
थैंक यू एवरीवन एंड
कल मिलते हैं फिर नेक्स्ट सेशन में। बाय-ब
एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन।